[Music]
to
monday
it is
march the 21st
live the h3 podcast back again against
all odds
today i think at the top of our show
real fast hello fresh
look at this delicious tortilla soup
i think that's what it is right what's
that little dollop on the top though
uh that looks like hummus
it does
looks good whatever it is i'd eat that
[Music]
that this is just a few of the delicious
meals that we've tried through
hellofresh and with over 50 menu market
items to choose from you can try
something new every week get 16 free
meals plus three free gifts with code h3
tv 16 at hellofresh.com
h3tbc
thank you all right welcome everybody
thank you lina
dan you gotta cut me off for two hours
cause my throat is not healing oh okay
i'll cut you off i'm just going to end
the stream with no prompting i'm just
going to middle of a sentence going off
the air
that's what i need because
i was hoping that i would get better
next last week and we were doing like
three four hour episodes
it's just not getting better man yeah
and then on the weekend we had like a
friends come over with a bunch of kids
and
we were screaming dude like i mean we
were having fun but i was like you know
i'm doing a vow silence this weekend
because i need my throat to heal
[Music]
and then all the kid i was sitting there
pretending to be a
client at their
restaurant they kept bringing me too
much food
and i was like this is too much food and
they're all laughing
but i was screaming
they loved it when i screamed how am i
supposed to not
[Music]
this is too much food are you out of
your mind
there was like five kids just piling
food up on my plate
you see our
new background for spring let me see
oh the flowers are blooming move your
head a little bit just decide look at
that a little bunny rabbit little bunny
rabbit
is that a real bunny that's a real bunny
they move that fast
he was kind of moving like a bird oh
yeah
oh yeah they move oh we got a bunny
rabbit yeah dude
okay
it works
and um
well i gotta get well because this
friday baby
it's all going down
before
the whole gang is going to
vegas
the whole freaking gang well we should
talk about what that means for the
schedule this week
oh god i just puked in my mouth dude i'm
having such a hard morning
i don't know all i had was water
like i literally like one of those like
stomach acid little cough ups yeah it's
the worst what did what the [ __ ] did i
do all i literally just drank water
curd game baby
that's i think that's part of the reason
why my throat is so messed up too
because you've got like a gerd situation
with the
um
yeah so we're doing um friday on
thursday
so that we can all take off early
and have a full day
at vegas it's like a pseudo it's like a
pseudo a b birthday party right i mean
you were gonna go there and then you
get an awful week for us what i thought
it was for my birthday yeah oh so it's
not even a pseudo it's not pseudo full
full blown a b birthday celebration
dirty thirty
season he's an old man oh wait did sam
ask you like restaurant choices because
you should decide no yeah sam asked me
yeah okay you decided i just told you i
don't want to just work with restaurants
so whatever you guys want no whatever
you whatever you want yeah see some
titties appreciate that
[Laughter]
so yeah you decide
what should we do baby i mean you're the
birthday boy should we you are just
gonna oh you're not gonna drink that's
right you don't drink keeping a hell out
of vegas yeah you keep it allowed in
vegas baby of all places in the world
yes i mean we'll have fun no matter what
and it's gonna be love's first time in
vegas too so that would be fun
i wonder i wonder if there's a mosque in
vegas we could just go pray that's
actually very interesting i wonder if
there is i mean that's a good way to
keep it right hotel
where's the closest mosque to the strip
just so
since your parents are watched just in
case you're yeah parents
that we can go do our three times daily
prayer five five oh five five times damn
what do you how do you all got time to
do anything in a day
it's tough it's not easy how long is the
prayer session when you do five a day
i mean it's not that long it's pretty
quick
yeah can you do it at home it's not like
you
five times a day though how do you do it
at home
what if you have a job
oh you're supposed to be able to work as
well okay
[Applause]
[Music]
it's just a quick hey how are you
uh a little bit longer than that i'd say
about a couple of minutes okay that's
not bad yeah yeah we there is a moscow
pretty close to the strip right around
the corner from the mob museum oh we'll
fit so yeah
so just in case your parents are
watching we're going to basically be
um
having coffee
and then we'll go to the mosque for a
quick prayer together we'll take a break
in between get our prayers come back
maybe um
catch a movie
yeah bowling mm-hmm
that'd be nice
but no other than a b i think
and are you allowed to gamble gambling
in the hollow right no game looks not
hello yeah so i don't know how to gamble
to be i mean like i don't know how to
play anything
we're gonna have to avoid the casinos
you know just stick to the mosque
well if it's i don't know
ab and i got some new uh tire for this
weekend we're looking forward to it okay
so you guys are both
the drivers
i'm driving yeah is everyone but
everyone's not gonna fit in your car
my car's gonna be me lena love and cam
so then zach you're driving yeah yeah
[Music]
fun
we got some times baby suits we're gonna
look fly as [ __ ]
you really bring in suits i didn't buy a
suit i'm clarifying i
wow you're supposed to i mean it's cool
to dress up i'll just nice i have a nice
outfit i'll wear that
[Music]
that one you were last time for the
month
the outfit you were last time in vegas
with like the gucci slippers oh yeah
that's what i'm going to wear yeah that
was fine yeah that's what i'm going to
wear
i have a few ensembles
nice to go lose money then
sweet
but anyway
very much looking forward to it and you
know eli hasn't been able to drink
anything and uh
god it feels like forever i mean almost
a year now so
it's gonna be wild and reckless in the
words of ryan cavanaugh wet wet and
reckless we're gonna be wet and reckless
out there boy
it's gonna be good times
i was thinking we should just go up to
the um
roulette table and i'll just put a
thousand on black
love was saying he was going to do he
says he likes to
to go big on the roulette table right
love
oh yeah baby well i was just thinking we
can get the party started hopefully i
win and then you know i only go
what i only go green well you know
i was wondering maybe if one of us goes
green one goes you only go green [ __ ]
yeah baby i'm going bigger going home
well how much are you gonna put on green
nah okay let's say
400 bucks i split it maybe in 20 20 bits
wait why do you how do you know how to
play roulette
cs go you know how to describe it and do
all that crazy [ __ ] yeah
i used to gamble cs go skins on really
oh my god dude
yeah
wow
yep
and how old were you
15 so 15 years old
putting thousands of dollars on a spin
you said
not per but definitely gambling
thousands dollars on it per day
that's how i think he's a very wealthy
man let's just put it that way yeah
uh t martin sends his regard right yeah
yeah i always played to rely on the
color i see first so if i see a person
walking with a red shirt that's what i
put my money on invite a sign from god
sign from god baby
and um
have you ever won on green before love
yeah big time jesus you must have played
a lot because one green is like 150.
yeah i won like yeah
i put 50 dollars on green ones
and what's the return on that like 25 i
think it's time 14. that's crazy
yeah
what are the odd what is the odds it's
one in 50 i think on green it depends on
the table some tables have worse odds
than others i think it's 1 in 28 no
i have no idea oh maybe well some have
two greens yeah and
also have one green they have 30 black
30 red one green i shouldn't challenge
you man you know you should i'm not sure
i'm not sure i i even i barely know how
to play that game
yeah i can't wait though you guys can be
fun
you could smoke inside in vegas it's
pure debauchery
can you believe there's places in the
world you can still smoke inside it's
heaven
big old cigar 1 in 35 ab
informed me it's 14 pages
yeah
well anyway let's get started guys give
us a call at 808 hot meme
um
love to hear from you
and in the meantime
they call them dumps dj khaled is
anti-non-binary
yeah did you hear very disappointing oh
no yeah he's coming wait what the [ __ ]
is this shirt bro oh that's not what
that means no yeah so this has been
going around on twitter he's because
they don't want you to win
but that's that's a
that's a hilarious [ __ ] shirt bro
but do people actually think he hates
non-binary people well this tweet went
like mega viral um i have to imagine it
being twitter that like a good
percentage of those people didn't get
that can you read the comments on that i
want to get a sample
dj khaled doesn't have a thought about
non-binary people i'm pretty sure
he's he's focused on the other they the
ones that are trying to bring him down
yeah definitely don't want him to win
specifically another one
you know that'd be hilarious shirt if it
didn't have the dual meaning
right well i imagine because he was
talking about they don't want you to win
eight years ago or whatever oh yeah or
it came into the public consciousness
yeah
they them pronoun thing here let's let's
read the responses and
get a sample of the people out there
here let's look at the quote tweets
that's a good way to do it
y'all stupid okay
still don't know
someone airdropped me this and i still
don't know who did it
i think people are laughing
mostly yeah yeah they seem to get it
that's good okay
oh you can buy it guys good news
[Laughter]
oh it's on we the best
or no it's not
it's on some
wait is it it's on this man this guy
definitely set up this shop this bootleg
is merch
all right
well shout out dj khaled
um
salt bae is a weirdo i knew that
there's a new salt bae drama
what the [ __ ] is this dude
i want to tell you something special
las vegas heart of world
entertainment casino are you talking
money like i know he has an accent but
why does he talk like this
like he's a ninja turtle
i have a theory about salve but i i can
tell you after the video though
go ahead
i don't i think he's more than one
person i think no more than once oh do
you think he's got body doubles that's
way more interesting than i thought it
was gonna be like you
it'd be easy because he wears sunglasses
and it's like a man wow you know what
how is he in all these cities at the
same time you always see him serving
meat right and he's in he's got a
restaurant in new york with the
conservatives
whatever the [ __ ] l a
who's serving all these meats in the
mouth right i i think there's more than
one i might be on board with this
wow the multiverse the self a multiverse
comes
money go
all the time
nightlife 24 hours
show
enjoy yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah right
we know about vegas because this guy
sounds like he's like trying to do a
salt bae accent or something but we
don't really see salt bae talk exactly
this is salt bae
this is the instagram you know what you
would he wouldn't let it imposter
well i'm saying he's got impostors on
his payroll that's interesting i'll
entertain that yeah
you know what i am saying hello
everything
we're changing the game
okay we are number one in the world
because of you
thank you
so
las vegas
so he has a restaurant there he's
opening a restaurant there because it
seems like he just really likes vegas
more than anything yeah he's just kind
of rattling off he's like listen i love
vegas
no sleep all fun
best city all right see you guys later
he does have one in vegas though
yeah yeah
that'd be funny to go there get a b get
him to feed a b by knife point oh god
my favorite part i mean if he's there
evidently yeah he's everybody's in every
city what the hell is that the head bob
at the end
oh yeah we missed it we lost that's the
end of the best
entertainment casino does anyone say las
vegas is heart of the world
i don't think so i don't know about that
money comes
money go
all the time
nightlife 24 hours
show
enjoy not sleep you know what i am
saying
have everything
be changing the game
we are number one in the world because
of you
thank you
las vegas
this part is real weird
interesting
all right salt phase on some
where's the salt i heard it's like
insanely expensive it's like a thousand
bucks for like a tomahawk steak
and i think it's
i i've seen lots of people
uh professional chefs and stuff saying
that it it's terrible
like it's overpriced and it's like well
you know it's not seasoned well because
he [ __ ]
just does it's like that's not how you
season a steak dude it's because the
impersonators are making it the og salt
bay is traveling around the world i'm
telling you maybe he's even retired it's
like the the dread pirate robert
robertson or whatever it was you know
it's just it's a title more than it is a
person right passes around
another video for y'all
top of the show it's a sad day
first day at work as a shopping cart
attendant
did you see this no not yet
it's a hard day's work though yeah i
know that
you know
a thankless job really
and uh
lots of ends lots of outs for sure
it's just not an easy job
sorry about that
[Laughter]
[Music]
i mean it's just not an easy job dude
it's just it's tough
this poor man
i mean the man deserves some dignity
he's he's what he's not young
well there were light impacts at least
yeah it wasn't too bad yeah
i could ima i could imagine myself in
that situation you know
give it a little push that was risky
to give it a push sorry about that
and hope that the momentum holds it
oh [ __ ]
poor guy
oh miss ya
that's funny though
yeah we're gonna have to find out where
he works okay we need to harass him
please no just kidding obviously you
[ __ ] degenerates
yeah if we need to send this video to
his boss okay yeah
and we need to track his uh we need to
track him on linkedin and send this to
all future employers i want to know
whose parents are where they live
i don't where
i'm not even going to say that
yes some people were
the the
you know i don't even want to get into
it
so they all are just [ __ ]
some of y'all out there
takes you way too [ __ ] far
right
yes that's putting it nicely
[Laughter]
weirdo bro
hey guys oh this is huge news okay let's
watch this first the tesla jump
you guys probably saw it i mean it's all
over social media
the first place i saw interestingly
was dirty dom
trying to take credit for it he's such a
weirdo man
he's so pathetic dirty dom
i heard the police wouldn't talk to him
actually
i mean good
i mean it wasn't him idiot
but what's weird to me
is that this video is still up like i've
got i've had videos removed
for being dangerous for the dumbest [ __ ]
yeah and this guy like jumped at tesla
20 feet off the ground
so i was curious and then without any
warning this happened like as if he's
done it a million times before no
practice runs no warning
holy [ __ ] all right well they're telling
us to park here and get out so
dude that is insane
that's just where people live that's not
even like it was a residential
neighborhood
oh you can see from another angle he
crashes into a parked car too yeah at
the very end you guys have other angles
because i feel like the other angles
make it make it look even worse
[Music]
oh here
look at that
it almost hit like
and then it hits that car at the end are
you kind of surprised it got that much
air though i mean it almost looks fake
like it's insane
look at that dude
it's like 20 feet off the ground
nobody got seriously injured
the car could have flipped you know yeah
i mean it was actually close to flipping
yeah
i guess at the beginning he says
so i'll play this too he goes this is
very dangerous don't do this youtube's
going to remove our podcast for showing
david right we're going to get a strike
this is very dangerous don't do this i
don't condone this this was done
under strict supervision by
professionals never do this at home
[ __ ] you youtube
did he really say it was done under
supervision i don't know he gave a
warning at the beginning
[Music]
what you're about to see today is
extremely stupid very very dangerous i
mean people could have been [ __ ]
killed today they are so lucky to be
alive and for the love of jesus
please do not try this at home or ever
or anywhere unless you have a youtube
channel named whistling diesel
whatever he said okay youtube just don't
remove my [ __ ]
well at least it wasn't him i wasn't an
impression it was him
right he just i guess we don't know who
was driving that's just an accessory
yeah he was just there
right
so
oh you got to get me i guess who
inspired this trick
get take one guess
dubrick
dubrit
18 million views i wonder who inspired
this they shouldn't do it yeah no [ __ ]
susie what am i supposed to do he's
[ __ ] 300 pounds i'll kick my ass they
should do it oh my god and then he turns
off the camera guys you have to do all
right now go do you have to do this do
it
come hold on let me get it let me get my
camera so awesome yeah
give me your keys i said okay
oh it's in his car
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god
my hands are shaking i was like so
scared look at my heart
when david hears that zayn's drunk
so there you go eh
people are still saying it's dirty dog
we'll find that video
it's in the duck oh it is yeah
is it it's just so poetic that david's
the one that inspired this yeah
uh dirty dom claiming in a bunch of
videos he posted that he was driving the
tesla
he also claims he was under the
influence
what a guy
but the guy who posted the video
alex choi says don
had no involvement which i i believe
i mean guys dirty dom hires david
look-alikes yeah and he's known for just
doing that in the past taking other
people's footage and pulling it off like
it's his so
i love this though he's wanted by the
lapd
yo it was a hit and run
they left
they yeah
yeah they didn't leave like insurance
info or anything for they hit a car yeah
i just bailed there's a it's in it's
below that but there's a guy fund me for
the guy and he made a video
it is
this alex uh choi is that his name yeah
he he seems to be under the impression
that like
oh i'm not involved i'm just here you
know you shouldn't do this and that's
gonna get like
you're directly involved dude like
i don't know why he thought it would be
a good idea to post a video of a crime
that he was like you witness an accident
i think you're supposed to pull over and
get the license plate and stuff yeah
and he's claiming he doesn't know who
was driving which like sure like it's
possible i mean maybe it's possible he
didn't know him i mean he he teases who
who did it at the start of his video
he says
uh don't try this at home unless you're
whistle diesel
which is a car youtuber so it might have
been that person
and that person said it's just a joke
about maybe about babies
i don't think lapd is going to find it
that funny i'm like oh well ellie
they'll find out
for sure they actually have a thousand
dollar bounty
yo they have a offering one thousand
dollars for any information leading to
dom's arrest
no way bro
yeah so here's the video he post this is
the first thing i saw too
wait
oh [ __ ] this video is still up on tick
tock with like 12 million views or
something [ __ ] up bro
guys i just woke up
i don't even know what happened last
night i was so [ __ ] up off these guys
right here
oh my god oh my god he's so trolling
trolling epic under the influence
uh
car crash
do a little trolling it's called we do a
little god he's so tragic
[Music]
this guy has nothing
of value left in his life
next he's going to claim credit for like
a school shooting or something
he'd be like yo i was what happened last
night bro
he i think it's all for promo for those
gummies
because he's a partner or he's always
advertising them i don't know
what the deal he's like dude i was so
these companies are so dope i hit and
run you guys are gonna want these
man
he has nothing left to lose crazy
yeah
um
it's missing one of his tick tocks that
i saw where he looks like super [ __ ]
up and then
he shows the crash
i mean that's the main tick tock there
was a screen cap of it in that deaf
noodles i don't know why you didn't show
it
he's not he doesn't want to show it on
instagram yeah maybe
instagram
i just saw britney spears butt naked
yesterday don't care
yeah whatever it's just as i crashed my
new tesla
only just took his fifth one oh
so epic
what is wrong with you man
i have such a hard time believing that
guy would essay someone
yeah right it looks like
okay
i think
either he deleted or tick tock finally
deleted his his original post
yeah because he's portraying it like
look at this guys yeah not like some
dangerous thing that happened it went
like mega it had over 10 million views
last night when i saw it
epic
wait so the tesla hit a parked car it
was hit who's jordan hook that's the
person's car
so another youtuber's car got hit he
wasn't a youtuber he uploaded a video to
youtube okay okay so this is the guy
jordan hook music who they hit
dude alex alex choi
you were there this year you dig hit and
run bro
what the hell what's up guys my name is
jordan hook and uh i was awakened last
night by a pretty loud crash you might
know me as the owner of the blue subaru
that the tesla jumped into last night
when they did car pranks on my street
here in echo park
got woken up about 12 30 to a big crash
after they plowed through some trash
cans and glanced off one of my neighbors
cars they came down here and hit my car
pretty bad and
despite what they say online the back
isn't messed up but they jacked up my
front tires and my steering column's all
messed up my suspension's all blown so
the car's done
so if you guys think it's not cool that
youtubers go to your street and jump
their teslas and wreck into people's
cars in the middle of the night um i'd
appreciate anything you have so that uh
i can get back up and running again
thank you so much what the [ __ ] dude
yeah you set up a gofundme which which
already blew away how about alex troy
pays for your [ __ ]
i think he did someone who shot just
said that he donated two thousand
dollars okay i'm not sure though
probably there's probably a more
official way to do that for him right
but that's good let's see what he's got
my boy's about to wait 20 000 oh
does he need 20 yeah i guess so if his
car is destroyed
wait i thought it already yeah alex troy
gave 2 000. is that enough
like not to be a dick but is that enough
no you should buy him a new car
i don't know alex joy's financial
situation though i mean he's a fairly
big youtuber yeah it that shop looked
pretty nice
i don't think that's enough alex
well he wasn't the driver though
he made a whole video about it
that was profitable yeah right probably
made way more than two thousand dollars
from the video yeah it's over a million
views already so you know i probably
demonetized actually
right let's see i'm going to open it in
cognito and see if there's ads
i hope you do demonetize some video of
them hitting and running a car
uh cam said he got ads on it yeah i
don't think it's demonetized bro
well that's weird so alex let's see
those analytics
i think you should get it all bro
wow i love this whole story though with
the guy we got the update from jordan
who was it
who was driving that thing
wait the interesting part of this video
is that he also cited in the description
that alex copyright strikes his video
no [ __ ] shot yeah
hold on let me reopen that
alex joy had the audacity to have my
first video removed
because i used to clip he took of the
tesla hitting his car
he coordinated document and bragged
about it
did he do all that
you guys find any
well i mean
in the video oh he's talking about the
video yeah i mean
video itself
i'm sure i'm guessing it was an
automated thing
probably because i can't see
why he would do that like that only
makes him look so much worse but that's
still pretty [ __ ] it's not cool to
have um
it's not cool to have automated strikes
on though damn
the dudes go fund me if you scroll down
you can see
that that alex copyright strike took it
down wait how do i see that sam
oh i guess on the gofundme put a
screenshot of uh oh let's see okay i
want video getting struck
let's get some details here for
yeah
copyright strike by alex joy
okay i have a i have a question
i don't think the automated system can
issue a copyright strike they can only
block
so
actually
i think alex may have blocked it that
may have copyright strike this video
and it would have to be manual you're
saying
for it to be manual blocks only blocks
because for a copyright strike you have
to specifically file out the dmca
paperwork youtube will not automatically
file that for you right
wow
that's awesome
[Laughter]
yeah it looks like the owner has to do
it himself yeah who wants to lose some
money today
i got to know the context of that tai
lopez
he was doing a live stream i believe
yeah but
who wants to lose some money today
yo i think my boy did a copyright strike
on his video
oopsie
[ __ ]
that's some cold ass [ __ ] right there
damn
alex troy sweating right now
see somebody said if he lives in echo
park he probably has to have some decent
insurance yeah but i mean that can take
a while and like if you rely on your car
for
your livelihood in some way you know
i don't know
here
alex left a comment with his two
thousand dollar donation he said hope
you get your justice served here's
probably all the revenue i'll get from
my video
it's probably a little low it's probably
more than that
if he claims he doesn't know who the guy
was though then i guess what can you do
to be a devil's advocate
i watch this alex roy dude a lot how do
you watch every person i like cars so i
watch him you watch every channel
you know everything about everyone it's
amazing yeah but he's a good dude he's
pretty young obviously
um
yeah that's i just wanted to throw that
out there he's not one of those
obnoxious like young youtubers he's
pretty cool
that's all okay i think i think
a little bit yeah
i think i'm willing to to believe him
that he didn't know who the driver was
because it seemed like they kind of just
all randomly gathered there and then
right there's a bunch of people with
cameras
like a meet-up car meet-up yeah
i guess
[Applause]
there you go
alex joy everybody
um we're at uh 35 already let's uh let's
do our other ad
so um
let's do our we have one ad
yes sir
so let's thank
our
sponsor today honey
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or computer
love saving
love shopping online
honey makes shopping online even better
basically it seems like every time i'm
buying something
i'm getting a coupon saving
it's truly incredible
uh thanks to honey manual
searching for coupon codes
there's a thing in the past honey is the
free shopping tool that scours the
internet for promo code that applies the
best what it finds to your cart
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites and when you check out
the honey button appears and all you
have to do is click apply coupon wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site if
honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the prices drop
hey
what do we got here where's this from
another one she was buying something
from a craft store and though uh the
amount is low i mean look at this
it's a 40 purchase yeah
550 off i mean that's a great 20 yeah
almost complain you know 15 something
like that
what is this story grip
like an arts and crafts type place
probably bought some fabric or something
there interesting
so there you go i mean it works on
clothing tech food but eila got it on
clothing but it's all over the place
um
honestly i say a surprise but not
surprising anymore it happens every time
i shop
seriously saving hundreds of dollars a
month for free
without any effort or thought um that's
pretty much what honey does and it's not
just for desktop now works for your
iphone too just activate it on safari on
your phone save on the go
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the show
i never recommend something i don't use
so get honey for free at joinhoney.com
h3tv
that's joinhoney.com
slash h3tp thank you
[Music]
okay so
we have some ethan haters yeah
ben sounds interesting to me
where's the name
or number three
number three let's see
he's a pizza maker
and he hates ethan's pizza order
well
okay i'll talk to him i guess i mean i
don't see how lively that could be i
don't really know either i mean it's a
preference ben how are you how are you
gonna judge me for a preference ab
also now hey shouldn't you just be happy
people are eating pizzas
uh i mean yeah but not you
uh you shouldn't be happy about even
i mean okay go ahead
uh okay here describe to me your perfect
pizza brother
perfect pizza
listen i like basically any variation so
any variation i like black olives you
got a problem there
uh
no okay by themselves great
i like uh jalapeno
great great choice by themselves of
course
okay now combine black olive and
jalapeno good
i've also heard a bit of mention of
pineapple hold on i'm getting there
i'm getting there
okay so but so far we like the black
olive
and the jalapeno right
never reflect mine but we can we can
agree that those are both worthy pete's
top okay so now we've got
salty
and spicy
two
okay two cornerstones of flavors
everywhere ben
what are we missing
what are we missing ben and what's
pineapple something sweet to even out
the perfect triangle of flavors
tell me why i'm wrong
all right so what if i took some syrup
[ __ ] and
uh tapatio and put it on a pizza would
you like that does that sound good to
you that does have hey listen to the
triforce if you got a problem with
pineapple why the [ __ ] you put it in
your damn it's in your toppings
you don't do you store jizz uh
do you have a do you have a bucket of
jizz there with your pizza toppings
i'll have a problem with you pouring
water all over your pizza man it makes
it disgusting the pizza
do you have a bucket of water there
if someone says i like more pizzas than
any other person in the world but you're
wrong brother
does anybody else there eat your pizza
when you order it no
you probably sit there sad and eat the
whole thing by yourself nobody likes it
nobody i wish i could back you up
take a poll right now
they don't like it
i hate it and i think i'm sorry but ben
has a point because i i like all three
of those toppings i'm i'm a pineapple
pizza guy no you like hawaiian pizza i
like hawaiian pizza oh i don't get it
with the canadian bacon anymore but but
the pineapple's fine you like hawaiian
pizza ben
uh
well here i do have a topic on hawaii
what's up with you guys colonizing the
808 phone number
oh
what's up with you guys colonizing the
hawaiian phone number bro wait 808 uh
just use your social phone number you
got to colonize the hawaiian number two
the reason why
oh i'm sorry we got it we had to get hot
means we were trying every combination
of available numbers to get one that
like spelled something and i finally
found hot me but it was eight away yeah
well you're right we're colonizers
you're totally right wait are you in
hawaii ben
he is
there i live in kentucky now okay okay
oh so
you're why are you colonizing
[Laughter]
do you hate pineapple do you hate all
pineapples what kind of wine are you you
hate pineapple what are you doing yeah
yours james here exactly man
how why would i want to ruin such a
perfect delicacy on a trash pizza like
even pizza order
let me ask you a question ben
do you like pineapple on pizza
i do
really he hesitated
you're okay so in what situation
in what situation ben would you put
pineapple on a pizza
um
when it's pineapple on a pizza
oh so okay so you're eating just
pineapple on the pizza that to me seems
more disgusting than what i'm making
well okay
this isn't some kind of like domino
situation we got going on here okay i
got a cup of marinara i got you know a
little bit of pesto on the side i might
dip you know i i move around this is a
pizzeria you've been working with this
domino's trash i don't need dominoes you
don't even know what they think
yeah i'm sure all the best pizza in the
world in kentucky sorry there's nothing
wrong kentucky
that's where papa john lives i think oh
that's right excellent you're living i i
understand you're living in the shadow
of the great papa john himself
i understand the insecurity
i've never seen this foyer
i took a trip there when i was in
elementary school
to where
papa john's estate oh you did they give
they give tours of it
[Laughter]
picked your trash music on this waiting
call man that you need to find oh
you need to like get oliver to like
license you something or anything from
dude you're a hater bro you are a he's a
real hater wait what's the music on
waiting it's the it's the classic um
like
a 1-800 conference call hold music oh
why do you remember that it's just the
defaults
hold on i don't know and you're right i
don't know if i can customize it oh well
i might be able to let me if we can
customize it ben we're going to change
it that's that's a good thing that is
good
yeah thanks bro
all right what tell me what you're hey
ben what's your perfect pizza
ben what's your pizza
did he run away
coward
wow outside your walls ben dude he
bailed as soon as he put him against the
wall you're gonna own a pizzeria and
then judge people that put pineapple on
their pie i mean
don't put pineapple don't you know what
i mean pineapple is in every pizzeria
topping kitchen now people who put corn
on their pizza i think that's disgusting
in fact it's horrifying corn yeah
yeah that happens good no no i know dude
i worked at california pizza kids
people putting tuna wrong [ __ ] on pizzas
um
yeah corn isn't great
tuna
that we never did at my party in israel
they make a tuna and corn pizza
that's horrible that's worse than you
know i'm saying there are worse options
out there you're right then a little
pineapple that turns me on
papa likes it
[Music]
we should order the worst pizza possible
and then i'll try it like tuna and corn
and then you can tell me who even makes
that
domino's would do some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
like that they don't but they don't have
tuna like on on hand i hope
they got in the back man
we could probably make our own sam sam
could probably whip up a disgusting
pizza i think it's funnier if it comes
from an establishment okay all right
you know we can look around
in sweden i sent my like famous pizza
it's called africana
and there's banana curry onion and curry
powder on it and chicken
that sounds like one you know what
without the banana i'd get down with it
it's pretty wild but it's yeah it's
really good
it doesn't sound that bad the banana is
just odd though it's interesting it's
pretty good actually
yeah
bananas also aren't from africa there's
a hater pizza hater it's like
yeah
um
i have another hater here
this one sounds like a serious condom oh
i just got some some intel with a fan of
the show
of a place that has two and a pizza i'm
gonna look into it oh really yeah
man that's gonna be sad because i really
won't eat it
all right here here's a real hater
oh wait it's the place that we got the
[ __ ]
imitation swedish pizza from
viking yeah yeah because you have to go
to some weird european people to find
something crazy we have tuna pizza in
sweden so there you go brazilian pizza
has eggs i'm down with that
that could
that could be
interesting yeah when i was in germany i
lived there for a month on an exchange
trip in high school right
and i ordered a pizza with olives
do you guys put all of some pizza there
uh love sure okay because when i was in
germany i said i just want a pizza with
olives on it
you seem kind of confused by it he was
like
okay
when the pizza comes
cheese pizza with five
massive
whole olives with the pit in it i had a
feeling it'd be something like that just
like
yup i was like what in the hell it's
crazy
egg though i'd [ __ ] with that for sure
no problem somebody else just let me
know that we should check out the
domino's japanese menu apparently they
got some wild [ __ ] unfortunately i don't
read japanese so i'm not sure how useful
this is going to be but um
yeah uh
trying i'm trying oh
i'm gonna take a call from another hater
here okay
this sounds sounds like a real
condemnation guys
nelly hi
you're disappointed in me
yeah a little bit ethan i gotta say i am
a pretty big fan um but
um i feel like uh in the past few months
you've gotten pretty bitter not you know
i'm sorry
i mean you've been okay i'm sorry you're
right um
but
i feel like uh basically i just feel
like you could be a little bit more
sensitive towards the creators that you
want to make content with
because uh i don't know when it came to
like the nicocado thing i was watching
it from your evening client channel i
was watching the whole saga play out
and i was truly horrified it was like
watching a car crash in slow motion and
not being able to do anything about it
um
because like
okay i'm sorry like i said chubby girl
myself i get i get like
wanting to make fun of other people for
being fat or being being able to like
poke at other people for being fat like
there's a limit like you
there's some people you can't do that
with and nick was one of those people
and he kept telling you like hey i'm not
chill with this and you kept going um
you know and then it he ended up being
like i'm not [ __ ] doing this i feel
like you know people are gonna people
don't want to come on the show if you're
just gonna make fun of them right
i mean obviously some people deserve it
like you know
jordan peterson but uh
yeah
and ronnie kavanagh anyway
so nelly
obviously
makes a good point
obviously i know i took it too far with
nick
the thing with nick though it's kind of
was kind of a confusing thing for me
i'll tell you because with nick when we
first started talking about him
it wasn't really a plan to have him on
the show
but once he agreed to come on the show
i could have loosened up i really
misunderstood the dynamic there because
i thought we were
but i even you know even with like
friendly jabs or whatever i took it too
far i mean saying his butthole looks
like a cow vagina
[Music]
that was definitely
[Laughter]
here's why i'm confused
i mean the man is taking he's taking
gaping [ __ ] porn
and he so he's gotten he's got to know
i assumed okay i'm not going to say he
has to do something but
i'm assuming that he had kind of a sense
of humor about everything right that's
kind of how we saw nick as just like
this wild guy that's just doing all this
crazy stuff and so
i mean he has a huge gaping [ __ ] if
it looks like a cow vagina or not i mean
i guess it just i didn't think first cow
i didn't think it would have been i get
that yeah
that's his art you know that he's crap
you're you're offending him you know i
mean some people are really into that
[ __ ] um
i don't understand
yeah the gapers if you will
um yeah i feel like uh also i mean
this also continued on with jeff as well
like
um yeah you're right that went over the
car
but yeah you're right
you're right
okay i've been uh you're right
the thing yeah i mean usually when i
have guests that i don't have this kind
of like uh
contest contestion with
then it's not like the [ __ ] talking and
stuff like i'm not gonna go
but you make a point you know i i
i gotta ease up a little bit you know
yeah
i appreciate that
i'm gonna ease up for you okay
thank you i appreciate that i know
they're going to call me snowflake in
the chat but that's fine um what are
they saying are they champions [ __ ]
talk i don't really see anything but i
mean
when is the chat the chat's going to
find out where you live nelly so just be
careful double your uh
they're crazy just no majority of the
great people don't even comment
it's always
yeah no you make a good point any if
anyone who disagrees anyone who say
anything in chat just shut the [ __ ] up
dude the [ __ ] up
all right now that you take care all
right thanks for calling
youtube thanks for having me on all
right bye
look she's right i mean like
there were weird situations with the
both of them but
i could ease up if i wanted to have them
on the show i think you're just getting
old
oh hold on
i'm totally kidding
i was interested but yeah where
um
just to double back to japanese uh pizza
toppings real quick um
uh this kind fan who sent me the link
translated part of their menu for me
they have a pizza that is
topped with shrimp octopus mussels
asari
trabeculae you got a photo
peppers yeah i'm trying to pull it up
peppers cherries tomatoes parmesan mix
cheese white sauce and then it warns
mussels may have hair-like substances
attached to them but they are eaten with
fibers called bisous
there is no problem even if it is done
we have taken all possible measures to
remove the shell pieces but please note
that they may be attached or mixed in in
rare cases you might chunk down on
on
a
little
uh
air muscle uh
muscle hair
no the shell they were warning that the
the shells might be in there
uh i think it's this one
which i mean
it doesn't look that bad to be to be
fair i mean listen if you like seafood
that's great japanese people love
seafood not for me i would never eat
that yeah
it actually don't look that bad though
japan is all about the respect
thank you logan
we're clarifying there
but
no honestly corn and tuna seems work
weirder than worse than that
here's another popular chain pizza chain
and and i was able to google translate
this page let's see a demon slayer pizza
oh what's on the demons on the demon
slayer mayonnaise sauce it says uh it
doesn't actually let me click on
anything it doesn't look bad
maybe you're supposed to just look at
this and call it's just like an online
menu
oh maybe you can you make out your own
pizza let's see what kind of options
there are let's see
quarter series i guess maybe they don't
yeah they don't do that eh
all right
bomber
good times maybe we can find a japanese
style pizza place here in l.a
here ugg's race
has a story about um
she went on a date
and the guy had a surprise for her is
that right grace
yeah hey uh first of all big fan of the
show thank you so much i've been there
since the og new york days um
i'm a city kid myself but anyway
um
this i went on a date because i was in
my whole face and
uh
i don't usually go for like creative
type but this man was like off the wall
so i was like all right i'll branch out
i'll give him a shot
uh i met up with him and he was
quirky
he
told me anecdotally that for one of his
art classes
he had made
chocolate molds of his
dong
uh and turned it in for a grade
um
high art and i you know higher right
um
hi i'm dick i was like okay interesting
he sounds like he just wants to show
people his [ __ ] that would be my yeah
he's getting there's definitely some
perversion there like the first
opportunity he gets he's like
i'm gonna make a mold of my dick and
then let everyone see it i mean
he's a pervert he's our [ __ ]
i don't know he might he might just be
an exhibitionist one of his tender
pictures was him with a
heart reverse shaved into his chest
uh so the heart was made of the hair and
the rest of his chest was shaved so like
quirky kid
um red flags all over the place but you
know you do what you gotta do i got a
question um i got a question yeah what's
up was it bite size
regular king size the [ __ ] the chocolate
the chocolate
excuse me
i wouldn't ask about that that's
inappropriate about chocolate the
chocolate
it was life size so
it was a life size life size it was just
scale
just he straight up made a mold
no i get that and filled it with
chocolate and it was
uh
dan's asking how big is his cup
not king size not party
okay he did make a point of saying that
he was like oh it was only like 75
percent erect oh my god you got to be
kidding me he really said that that's so
funny he did a couple of times
he's like baby it was cold
it was cold that day
the wax was cold
all right um yeah and then so he had had
this and he made this for his art class
the prior
year so this had been sitting
naked on his bookshelf for like
almost a year and he goes do you want a
bite
oh my god that's disgusting like he and
he asked a couple times he was like no
no he couldn't even eat it like
wow
the flesh talk unrefrigerated just
sitting out for a year
it should have to be moldy let me talk
to you let me ask you some questions
so grace
you on a date with this guy
you ended up back in his his bedroom
okay
are you guys moving along in terms of
like
oh dear lord um here
the only way that i got through that
conversation was uh he smoked me out so
i was i was pleasantly out of my brain
in order to be able to move past that
okay so you guys you guys were smoking
but you guys did sleep together
ultimately
we did okay and it was probably the
worst choice i've ever made in my entire
life that bad huh
why was it so bad
uh well he did that thing that people do
where they beg to go in raw for a second
and then you tell them no and then they
say
anyway
um
just the tip i believe
just the tip
that dude what the hell um so he was
begging you to go in raw
just for a second just for a second
that's why uh yeah it was it was very it
was a very odd vibe because he just kind
of like broke the moment and was like
but can i go in raw um
no
um that's so
that's gross that's just wild yeah i
mean
knowing him he probably still had
chocolate like around the ring but um
so
did it match the mold were you were you
surprised was he lying about the 75
yeah was he matt
oh a thousand percent right
of course
yeah got him
all right well um
there you have it
thanks for listening
interesting yeah watch out you're in
college i'm assuming right
i am yeah guys listening
just put the condom on ever she'll be
very happy don't don't beg her to go and
raw it's weird bro
truly
just be just you know be be mature put
the condom on don't make her ask
just condoms just you know what i mean
that that's good that's hot right that's
sexy
there you go see i know things
all right grace take care be good thanks
grace watch out for those artistic types
apparently yeah
weirdos
there you have it
penis mold
it's a new one
you're a weirdo bro
there it is
wait now i have someone who wants to
defend my domino's pizza take
really
i'm not sure how deep down this rabbit
hole i want to go
we can circle back around to it
we got some other stories i'm deep
undercover we gotta we only have two
hours we we better talk about this ace
family thing or there's gonna be a riot
okay let's go to ace family where is
this ace family they're apparently
quoting youtube do you believe them i
don't nope
they're not even they're any more money
now more than ever yeah that was not the
time yeah
i think they're just saying they're
quitting so they can hype up this new
scam yes yes yes so ace family
one last scam
ace family says that they are quitting
youtube but before we go
one last job as they say ocean's 11
style one last ride boys
damned
so they're quitting youtube to travel to
focus on travel
you mean you could you don't have a
house
or that they're gonna flee the country
right and take the money and run
traveling and spending money on their
with their family spending time with
their family yeah
couch surfing you know between family
members traveling
they said they'll be posting maybe once
a month or once every two months the end
of the ace family here's a super cut
for you all to enjoy
so
this
bad news is which is today's title
how do you say this
this is the last year i'm like you say
it like i don't want to say it oh wait
last year okay keemstar
this is the last year
that the ace family will be on youtube
that sounds weird saying i know so let
me explain
we actually wanted
to make this video a year ago and we
wanted
a year ago to be our last year but we
just can't seem
to stop doing what we love to do which
is creating video he hates making these
videos i'm so sure
you got a job bro i get it you got to
earn money what are you going to go do
that pays as good as this nothing
nowhere [ __ ] weasley little
liar dude
okay hassan
preach deals for all of you guys but
this year we've been talking about how
we're going to make this year
2022 our last year on youtube because
next year in 2023 we want to do
a lot of traveling with the family what
i mean by traveling i mean probably
traveling for like half the year
what i mean is that there's you go
warren out for my arrest right then
and uh germany doesn't extradite so
[Laughter]
wait i'm a little confused because he
calls his fans the ace family
so could he specify traveling with the
family does he mean with bro you just
cracked the nut
traveling [ __ ] lying they're not his
family are they
i thought
oh we were your fans
are you taking all of us with you right
so like a travel vlog is that that's
exciting
yeah there's no [ __ ] way these goons
are quitting youtube
10 to 20 different places because
throughout the six years ago you know
what make me happy
travel
if i could just go see the world i'd be
happy
you hear people do that all the time
they're like i just need to travel
i just need to pick up my life
have no roots
be constantly on the move traveling
sucks
i mean like like theoretically travel is
nice to be somewhere new and
experiencing all that stuff but like
going somewhere
packing [ __ ]
sucks so bad
wakes me up early
what when you're broke it sucks oh well
yeah i mean
i could never enjoy a vacation before i
had this job because i'm just thinking
about how much money i'm spending while
i'm gone for these two weeks is gonna
set me back for like six months
yeah for sure you know
and now that i do have money i have me
and either haven't had we don't go on
vacation you know we have kids so what
the [ __ ] am i gonna do you know me and
hila went to thailand for a month
back when we were in israel
we were broke of course we were living
in like hospital we were staying in
hostels and [ __ ]
but it was sick
get your [ __ ] ass up and work
oh extradition treaties okay great so
here's some possible suggestions well
russia russia's good place go to russia
china uh lots to do in china what's
those east european countries there oh
ukraine actually doesn't have
extradition with the united states so
maybe you could pop over there for a
couple months and then what's that one
in like the north west that little tiny
one
[Music]
this one no right above it top layer
uh
that's a good question i don't know
like estonia or something yeah one of
them so we have good options for you ace
family
we're gonna be doing a tour of russia
saudi arabia
saudi arabia and china vladimir putin
yeah and north africa
yeah
most of africa indonesia nice place i've
heard
i mean there's good options here not
gonna lie
we could hide out for a couple years
until things settle down it's kind of
incredible to me that like
a mass murderer can just go to one of
these countries and then
you can't get them
you'd think that extradition treaties
would be in everyone's benefit to
everyone's benefit
murderer
there you go
so yeah
you two we haven't
had the time to really reflect
and enjoy
and really
spend time with our family yeah you're a
family vlog
that's you what you do that's your job
we haven't had any time to spend with
our family you could your channel's
called the ace family
so this would actually be our first time
actually be able to travel
yeah is next year in 2023 and not only
travel but also work on some big big big
big projects
that we're super excited for
so i'm for example i'm working on an
influencer
uh coaching program
that's going to teach you how to become
an influencer in three easy steps
but to access it 100 gonna need to buy
this ace family nft let's see
nfp owners for ace conference but as a
bonus
you'll get exclusive access to early buy
the new ace coin which will be dropping
oh
that's right in reality you guys got
scammed
yeah fast forward a year he's like yo
turns out my partner really screwed you
guys damned i'm so sorry
my partner totally scammed you all
obviously like we don't want to leave
youtube like this is very difficult for
us and the fact that we're even it seems
like nobody wants to talking about it
now is kind of difficult for us but i
think that just putting it out there
letting you guys know in advance
is much better than just kind of like
not doing this anymore yeah but i think
today is really important because we
wanted to share with all of you
um
first before someone else creates our
own narrative and tries to make up a
story on why
we're
not making videos for youtube yeah next
year for example like let's just say we
you said you're not leaving for a year
you're like i'm worried about people
making up narratives in a year
something's fishy man with these i mean
we know that but
chatter uh had a great suggestion for
the name of their nfts instead of bored
eight board ace
board ace family
stopped
the news would be they broke up you know
and it's like we're just guys it's not
you're not leaving for a year
you're not you what is this
that's not the case like we're just we
just want to be like really up front
really honest with you guys like this
will be our last year because we
are telling you guys in advance and
because we have our own reasons and we
just explain those reasons so now you
guys know why also we're not saying that
we're gone forever we're just saying
that we're not gonna be as consistent
anymore we really enjoy what we do we
really love what we do
all right well that sounds all good but
wait
hold the phone
they're announcing as they're leaving
youtube
a new ace festival
that's right everybody
this is a
huge announcement in the same video and
ace family on youtube
hold the phone okay family and now our
next event announcement are you guys
ready
daddy's got a mortgage to pay
for this one a lot of you foreclosure to
bed yeah correct but also people have no
idea what we're going to do this year
and you guys have been waiting
i've actually made a little video for
you guys here it is check it out i love
this it's a little scam montage
all of our greatest hits this is where
we bought our house our first house
yo who the [ __ ] is working with him to
put on events at this point
like the last people that put on his
events for the social club they're in a
lawsuit yeah because they're saying
he's suing them saying they scammed
people
i don't know it's such a [ __ ] mess
who's working with this man great
question
[Music]
i'm blown away they actually sold that
many seeds i can't believe it the
staples one is what really did they did
they used to be more popular like how
could he fill up staples 17 million subs
18 million subs i mean that's a big
chance ah lee
it is pretty shocking yeah well i know
wait actually wait what am i talking
about i know exactly how they sold it
out they told everybody it was a charity
event right they lied
right and they had like a bunch they had
like crisp around there yeah
and like mr beast was there they
marketed the entire thing as a charity
james charles was there ace charity
event
and then
pocketed all of the proceeds 95 yeah
yeah chris brown what a nice scheme they
had dude that is awesome bro
god
yeah anyway we remember bro
he's like you remember when people came
to these we switched it up
yo you're not going to show the social
gloves yeah why are they showing this
yeah one of the biggest financial
disasters it's like sports history i
mean
the fighters have not been paid still
the only person who got paid was um
ace family
there's a lawsuit between him and the
and the promoters
dude you're showing us right now
[Music]
yeah
let's go
okay
fraud
yo grab all those clips off um
stockvideo.com yeah
yo you know what the last thing person i
would expect with like really detailed
safety
somebody's getting decapitated
bro ain't no [ __ ] way
i'm riding this [ __ ] when it's
provided by
austin mcbroom look at that [ __ ] dude
somebody's launching off that
guaranteed
i'm seeing that uh austin mcbroom may
have settled the social club's lawsuit
for three million dollar settlement who
paid three million just last month who
paid who uh
let's see i'm ringing out reports from
billboard live one agreed to pay out
three million to applicable pays from
the youtubers vs tick tockers boxing
event last year who paid you so
basically his company austin paid them
let's look at it and then i don't think
the the fighters ever got paid though
either like i i remember seeing bryce
hall saying he still hasn't been paid
recently
also catherine mcbroom lost the judgment
too she had to pay the guy like a
million bucks
yeah for what was it like the makeup
makeup thing yeah she did like a hostile
takeover
of her partner on the makeup company
that's why that's the main reason i'm
not buying they're quitting youtube like
they're so deep in the hole like how can
they afford to stop so deep in the hole
unless they're just planning on
just
banking huge off of this event unless
when you see the prices maybe maybe
actually
you know unless he actually made a
shitload of money from the social gloves
didn't pay anyone
i mean they probably generated like 10
million in revenue not nearly enough to
cover all the costs right but if he
somehow pocketed all that paid them 3
million stiffed all the guys
i don't know if that's what's going on
if that's the case you wouldn't got
foreclosed on though
all right so now that you guys stop
that's how it ended uh what we have is
all right so this is the ace fest let's
get the details down
here's the ace fest website
one last ride
oh
okay
so here we go
yeah where's your faces
it could be you
that's the idea
this is jordan i mean this is austin's
face you too could have two hairlines
i'm gonna hide that when i laugh
all right so ace fest let's see all ages
disneyland meets coachella [ __ ] no
which i don't get the coachella angle
because i
as far as i could tell there's no
musical aspect to this it's just it's
just a carnival it says ace fest is a
one day festival for people of all ages
starting from noon
to 10 p.m what so if you go through the
effort of bringing all these vendors and
rides out why just do it one day unless
you know it's going to be such a
disaster you have one day to get as much
money as possible yeah yeah
the ace fest has a variety of free games
free rides and free prizes
of course there's an admission so it's
not free
as well as free access to wildlife
animals oh my god animals are gonna die
people are gonna die this is gonna be so
bad
so it says wildlife animals and live
performers
think of this festival as the ultimate
family playground for you and your loved
ones that have the time of your life
ace fest official date and location will
be released
when tickets go on sale april 9th
ace fest admission
free everything
that you pay for
only five thousand tickets available
buy one before it's too late
well each ticket is for like three to
five people
so maybe 20 000 people roughly
total all right let's check it out
this one pass counts just three tickets
uh this uh 300 bucks
but it's a nine hundred dollar value
i'd like to know how they calculated
yeah i wonder that too
just looking at those bullet points does
that seem like 900 dollars worth of
value to you
how how
disneyland ticket is like 200 bucks
right
so this is
free rides free games
free prizes
i mean unless they're handing out like
uh
gold necklaces to everyone
free auto autograph poster
you [ __ ] serious you think people
want that [ __ ]
you get to go to carnival for one day
and you get a poster by the way that's
just two parents and one kid that's two
parents and one kid sure yeah so if you
have more than one kid better buy six
sticks get the gold pass
oh they have a gold pack or get the vip
too there's only two pads yeah there's
this one and then the one under it is
the gold library
okay so if you have more than one kid
this one counts as five tickets
for those families with three kids
here we go baby
500 bucks valued at 1500 bro what a
[ __ ] deal i better buy all of them
i need to buy every single ticket up i
mean the value is insane
flip it on stubhub
yo definitely
uh let's see
free autograph poster bro i need that
guaranteed to meet and take photos with
the ace family what
not happening no shot
if they sell a thousand
it's gonna be one
massive photo of them
probably you're right idiot it says meat
though
yeah
one day
okay wait 5 000 tickets
one day which is really like 20 000
tickets like right but that's what i'm
so i'm saying
if you have three kids or more than one
kid you're gonna want this vip pass
so let's say it all sells out and let's
say i mean i would say most families
have let's say half families have more
than one kid so he sells out there's
2500 vip passes
guaranteed to meet and take a picture
with ace family 2500 families
no he could do 100 in a day i've done
meet and greets yeah
you know a hundred people takes like
three or four hours
explain to me guys
how this isn't already a scam
and it's got a star on it too
god
damn mama
the best part's coming up watch austin's
next fight for free
yeah that's not happening which isn't
announced there's no details other than
it's going to be around july
so that's the thing they really want
people to buy these vips so let's i mean
how much do they want to sell three how
are you going to meet 3 000 families in
one day
you can meet maybe at max blast
250.
picking two vip pass members to join us
at austin's next fight plus your four
guests yeah i mean bring everyone you
know it's not happening
bring the whole town
back picking two vip fast members to
join us at our wedding what the [ __ ]
how many people you beat your wedding
well this really threw me for a loop
because i was like they're they're
married right like that was my
impression and i looked into it they've
been married since 2018. so they're
doing like a mock just wedding
another wedding i guess
that's their event for next year right
okay so
you can
bring
four you could bring six people to their
wedding
so if their wedding be at staples center
maybe
so it'd be eight people because two
people with those gold passes could
bring four people
for random you know it's worth it it's
so confusing
and you get a wedding gift
exclusive
what
oh actually i'm sorry 10 people it's
gonna be a shirt you can bring 10 people
it's you plus four guests okay so if
they sell i'm just gonna take your word
for it because i don't do the math but
i trust you
you get so let's say he sells 2500 of
these you bring 10 people that alone
right there is 22 500 people
where the [ __ ] is your wedding gonna be
dude i don't even think the staple
center can hold that many people
no no only two of all those tickets
say what out of all the tickets sold
only two of those gold pass members will
go to the wedding and then they can
bring five people with them each
yeah that's ten oh okay i thought you
were saying that the whole entirety of
the event well if there's 2000 if
there's 2 500 yeah
and there's 10 people right per
uh who cares [ __ ] it
but the point is
this is a lie
there's just it does it's impossible
it's impossible
let's say they were planning to have a
wedding
reception at the staples center
he's already he's already confirmed 20
000 people coming and he's saying they
get him for free it costs hundreds of
thousands of dollars just to reserve the
staples center and you know he ain't
taking a hell
he was bullshitting
guys
you are being scammed
in reality
how the [ __ ]
oh this [ __ ] yeah
key dates
so yeah i see what ab saying now they're
it's a it's just like a raffle if you
buy that vip ticket if you buy that vip
ticket you have a chance you have to go
to their wedding so in total only 10
people
are coming to their wedding
picking two vip pounds yeah they don't
they don't say it just says join us at
our wedding but yeah that makes more
sense than inviting uh oh 25 they're
picking two vip past members to join us
at our wedding plus four guests oh so
only 10 people total will come right so
so what are you actually getting for the
vip pass yeah well you'll get away you
get tickets you get five pants you get a
chance to go to their wedding maybe and
a chance to go to his fight maybe if it
ever happens two things you get a
wedding gift no matter what the wedding
gift is not part of a toaster
you don't know what it is it's gonna be
a key a panini press
one free month of the next
george foreman grill
[Music]
a blender
this is crazy 500 bucks man
here here's the timeline right below
that let's see what is it now there's a
place near disneyland that's basically
exactly this it's like a little theme
park
for families for toddlers super fun it's
called uh
adventure
island isla adventure
you can find the name
it's called adventure world or adventure
land or some [ __ ]
but anyway the admission it's a great
little place exactly like it's basically
exactly this
guess how much it costs to get in
50 bucks 25. okay yeah that sounds more
reasonable 25 for what it is and kids
get in free but do you get to uh take a
group selfie with the youtuber slash
washed up no neither will they be able
to
it was really fun i was super impressed
with it i didn't know what to expect
yeah it's 25 bucks
and theodore got him free because he was
so young let's go
go do that instead
it wasn't 500 bucks tell you that
it was 50 bucks
yeah um so here are those key dates
god my throat is killing me
i don't know if i need to see the doctor
or take antibiotics maybe
if it's been this long but i mean
well
you you do talk for a living and you did
it a lot last week so last week i pushed
it way too hard four hours on friday i
mean that's yeah then i was yelling i
mean if it makes you
more comfortable go see a doctor but
i just need to
i need to
talk less well we're at an hour and a
half right now we could just finish this
up and do maybe like one more little
quick goof goofing no we'll do call it a
short day
we'll do it
i gotta do at least two sure so here we
go key dates exact dates
key dates june
all right those aren't here's your curry
date
[Laughter]
picking two random vip past members
plus four guests to join for the fight
okay something to look for in june we're
going to be picking two people it's a
key date
in july
austin's next fight
not happening
yeah who's gonna put that on who's gonna
fight him the last guy that fought him
never got paid like who would not agree
to do that the vendor didn't get paid
the boxer didn't get paid and this guy's
putting on another fight
guys look for august
ace fest
after ace fest picking two random
vip members
to join us for a wedding who which
they're already married and nobody knows
what the [ __ ] that means
in september guys here's a key date the
month of september is a key date
the wedding and exclusive wedding gift
which actually is it turns out to be a
uh
i mean this is a
assuming any of this really happens
i mean putting on a giant festival
with like performances and meet and
greets and like carnival rides and
everything that's a massive undertaking
that like years years of planning you
watching fire festival they're like he's
like we need to do this in like eight
months they're like you're insane
impossible yeah yeah i mean you first of
all
i mean you need to get like it's almost
april first of all
you need to get
permits from the city and right now
things take forever because everything's
backed up from covet
you guys don't even have a date yet
no they do almost april key date is
august bro right
this is the big i'm surprised they're
not already selling tickets to be honest
you know uh soon it goes on sale uh
early april so
for all you super troopers out there
that think this would be a fun time for
your family
yeah i mean
turn notifications on for ace fest yeah
and they wanted to let the audience know
that if you want to pay in payments
that's also an option they said they
take paypal so you have to pay all at
once oh that's good installments
yeah that's good that's fair
by the way this website is making me
crazy it's horrible right because
normally you want to avoid using
pictures because it slows it down and
google won't know what the website is
about so it won't come up in search
engines
and the last picture further down
and that one you want
you won't be able to read that those
takes on phone
because they will be small
and you're right about the search engine
because when i tried to look it up
before the show i was having trouble
like if you type ace fest this doesn't
yeah i'm not it's horrible because
there's no text for google to understand
oh i can't wait for these to go on sale
how do these guys still have fans i mean
they literally just scam people every
year
i guess they just their fans don't pay
that close attention and like huh
well the charity stuff i get they didn't
they they got the event
they got the event at least that
actually that's true you know
yeah i mean the boxing event what do
they care if bryce hall got paid and
they're just like not as i mean we're
hyper tuned to all this like youtube
scamming stuff because we talk about all
the time but if you're just a casualties
family fan i got the impression from
their the footage that we watched of
those events that it was a lot of
younger families that have kids they
probably watch it together
probably not savvy
yeah exactly on youtube drama and [ __ ]
april 9th guys let's set a date
should we get the vip package oh hell
yeah imagine if we won the tickets to
the wedding
send you today to austin mcgroom's
wedding
like he wouldn't have his mom win those
or something you know
my mom won tickets to the wedding
there you go guys this is huge man it's
exciting
can't wait to see this all involve uh
unfold
i don't see how this isn't a huge
[ __ ] catastrophe
new store are you guys not excited that
we have the funnest festival coming oh
my god what do you guys think to be
honest we think this is gonna be the
best one yet so yes ace family tickets
go on sale april 9th mark it down your
calendars right now you guys should be
like this right now
all right so we're going to break this
down to you guys okay really listen this
is important
so every event that we have sells out in
seconds you guys know this yo is that
true is this going to sell out one of
you guys better get on that
they're sure to emphasize that every
event they do sells out immediately so
make sure you're there and if you don't
have the money right now use that paypal
option to pay payment okay let's hear
whatever you guys get on the website to
buy purchase tickets um there's usually
like oh i wanted to calculate the money
so they say there's 5 000 tickets
available
so let's say
the average price of a ticket is like
100 bucks pretty much right
well no but they sell they're only
selling tickets in these package things
it's either but it has a certain amount
of tickets so like 500 bucks gets you
three tickets yeah but when they say 5
000 i assume that's 5 000 packages not
five thousand
individuals yeah what does that mean
i mean it's a little vague but that was
my assumption because 5000 seems small
for an event like this i mean their
previous events but did you see their
map
i mean is that anything real or official
or well i mean photoshop
oh what the [ __ ] is it called ace family
fest that's not it ace fest
just ace fest what's the domain name
yeah here it is
i got it
yeah i wanted to do some calculating how
much rev they're going to generate here
here look at this
means
coachella so it says
5 000 tickets available
but then they say
this one pass counts as three tickets so
follow the logic of their website which
may not be accurate right then there's
only that's a safe bet really
so yeah three tickets
is 300 bucks
and the other one's five for a hundred i
mean if they really are only selling
yeah it's a hundred bucks a ticket
so that's half a million
right half a million bucks
that's not enough money for them to get
to
that's why i'm thinking more that they
mean 500 or 5000 passes which well a lot
of these places
bank on making a lot of money inside
with concessions and they said all of
the rides and stuff for free the rides
are free but what about food and drinks
and water and chips yeah i guess that's
true
that's not enough money
maybe they just didn't plan out that
well that's that's not even gonna go a
tenth of the way to paying off bryce
hall
[Laughter]
they owe him five million bucks
man
all right let's hear let's hear him out
waiting list of people and you purchase
and then if you
happen to like not put like a
ticket in your cart or whatever like
you're kind of like just
you're kind of screwed okay you're kind
of screwed but we've learned from past
experiences over the years of doing
multiple events
and that's why this one's gonna be the
best one because of the way that we
structured this so we thought about this
very carefully i do want to say that
because this is a festival
this is all ages so you can bring your
kids you can bring your grandparents
your friends you can bring anyone with
you and clearly ace family this event is
different than all the other events
we've ever had instead of you guys
sitting in your seat and just watching
the show you guys get to actually be a
part of the event you guys get to go on
rides you guys get to play games you
guys get to interact with all the other
ace man members you guys get to hang out
with us like it is literally a full
experience this will be our first
official meet and greet so we've done
one other like smaller meet and greet as
a family
um
this is not happening
it's difficult i can't wait to see what
happens
yo so we will be on the run next year
from the law right and the reason for
that is because of this festival we're
planning on putting on
uh here soon
ah they're the best man
all right before we go
i do want to talk about
uh trailers new l's plus
ratio it's been a while since we talked
about trump yeah it has that's kind of
what spurred me to google what's been
going on and sure enough there was
actually just news uh yesterday about uh
hey did you guys um has anyone looked at
the reviews lately because a judge
basically said that
us looking and talking about the reviews
doesn't amount to
doesn't amount to a crime or anything so
i thought hey you know since we're
since
especially since we won that court case
why don't we look at some more reviews
and just see what kind of reviews people
are leaving
you know
i opened it
and literally one of the first ones
we'll pop it up
oh it's so flipped
it just went to the app store open it up
definitely not ethan klein
this app blows and it's sierra uh bears
a striking striking resemblance to
disgrace movie muffle mogul harvey uh i
i'm assuming weinstein is what the
remainder for the record i did not write
this or
i'd not tell anyone
i'm telling you guys you know don't
leave meme reviews yeah con serious
reviews only it's just interesting that
even after all this time that's like
right right up front on there man a lot
of the top ones are really low
why does this app exist for some nature
that's what i want that's what i keep
wondering
yeah re read some of those there this
one looks like it's legitimate
yeah go ahead hate the changes
still so i haven't been on triller in a
while
before i used to just create uh fun and
carefree music videos and let loose
while being stressful college decided i
wanted to go back blah blah blah blah
re-download the app change the format
after you record
uh
this seems like a real review there you
go one star one star ryan cavanaugh
wants to blame me for that oh
pulling the plug
read the ethan klein one not ethical one
uh
i initially downloaded this app because
i thought it would be a viable
alternative to tick-tock which my
step-kids say i'm not allowed to
download because i'm embarrassing but
boy oh boy was i wrong the functionality
of this app leaves a lot to be desired
it performs about as well as my wife did
when giving me a colonoscopy last
weekend she has no medical training
whatsoever
content i found on this app has been as
entertaining and engaging as listening
to drew ackerman podcast but at least
ackerman puts me to sleep
the app could have potentially redeemed
itself with celebrities like kevin hart
who were advocating yeah i'll be using
the app where i noticed anything but the
front page is about as barren as the
moons of tatooine huh wow recently did a
google search for triller ceo ryan
cavanaugh i couldn't help but think he
bears a striking resemblance to
disgraced movie producer harvey
weinstein right
at first i thought that must be a
coincidence but there is no such thing
as a coincidence
right kavanaugh's former business
partner also accused him of running a
ponzi scheme in uh an article written by
esteemed folks over a variety magazine
they they uh just a small note they
later retracted that
yeah yeah yeah the variety did yeah
please fix this horrible app i hope
others will consider leaving an honest
review of this happy shortcomings in the
meantime one star app oh they've they
responded responded thanks for sharing
your feedback we read every review
they says can you share your thoughts
about what would improve the app
[ __ ] they don't work for you
figure it out
you're looking for free labor this the
person was kind enough to take the time
to write a review just read it and fix
yours this is the feedback that's your
feedback you got it drive angry
drive angry
yes so you know i encourage everyone to
continue to leave uh fair
thoughtful reviews try the app after
trying the app
and then give your honest thoughts if of
the app
i don't think we talked about it but
dixie demilio gave her own uh review of
the app on twitter when someone asked
her about it no way yeah i put in
discord no [ __ ] way dude
yo brian kevin i'd be like dixie
demilio's ethan klein i don't know what
she said
where is it in discord
oh you put in the wrong wrong chat sorry
what's great too is uh
they're still
promoting dixie
on their youtube channel just like
within the last week
which uh
i don't think they'd be doing if they
saw what you thought of their app no
[ __ ] shot this is real yep i i
checked
yo
yo they they paid dick they like bought
dixie a rolls-royce they were like
trying so hard to get her hey dixie you
forgot to update us on trailer it was
[ __ ]
no update
wait
wait i don't think it's what you guys
think it is
what do you mean i think she was like
you forgot to update us about something
on triller
and then she said there was no update it
whatever it was was [ __ ] that's why
there was no update
[Music]
that's how i'm reading that
i'd love to be wrong well they are still
cause of 10 days ago posting stuff about
her on their youtube channel as well
dude this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] weird i
discovered this the other day they have
all this like
deepak chopra meditation stuff being
posted on there 180 100
dylan francis and deepak chopra
meditation yeah by the way reminder that
triller lost 800 million dollars last
year i wonder how that happened is it
because they're paying deep rock joker
and dylan francis to make a video with
180 views
[Laughter]
super high production value what's that
frame rate like uh five
it's just an inappropriate relationship
with a fourteen year old not only
department insanely like but
underexposed this is content that nobody
would watch yeah this is not watchable
content so just
see what comes up when you say
i'm dylan francis
i'm dylan francis
he's like don't talk though
that's 188 views
any comments
one
who am i what do i want this is right
this is what is my friend
this man is a content genius
should i leave a comment
sure uh you should what are you gonna
write oh just great content
that cool
that's great yeah yeah yeah
no it's valuable that's good i mean they
said they wanted feedback
[Applause]
let's keep looking at i love this this
is their website huh this is their
youtube channel they have a bunch of
these deepak uh
deepak
the deepak
oh no fans are worried about little
hoodies oh me too
triller tv you would be like they're
like yo we're losing 800 million last
year how wow
i don't understand
we we produced this whole show for 100
views
140 uh 114 excuse me
i'm pretty sure they're suing me for
less views than that so i guess it is a
lot to them
i think the video they're suing us for
30 views so he's like dude that's a
[ __ ] lot bro we got 114 on our videos
pop off
oh
yeah yeah so we got you know energy
let's watch this i'm worried about
little honey davis fans are worried
about little honey
west is ready to battle kim kardashian
for custody kid cudi introduced all
right i'm out
it's just generic ass [ __ ] um he's
an astute businessman that rank well
so take a look at what i put in the dock
what they're spending money on now
because this this is breaking news
actually this was just yesterday or two
days ago trailer announces in a press
release this morning just this morning
eh
yeah i guess it was this morning yeah
now uh announce a go public transaction
wait they will acquire a pillow fighting
championship
mm-hmm
i see that i see that being the future
of sports
there's a quote about from ryan in this
article which isn't really an article
it's just a press release but it's
written as if it's like an article here
listen this triller augments the
greatest roster and combat entertainment
did you just refer to pillow fighting as
combat entertainment
trailer is now the world's most
competitive oh and a family-friendly
combat sport
um
trailer the ai powered open garden
technology platform for creators start
how many times again buzz for words can
you try again slam into this sentence
how many
try again
triller the [ __ ] graveyard
tick tock clone
uh announce [ __ ] what happened
announce that it entered into agreement
to acquire the world's most
family-friendly company in combat sports
the pillow fighting championship
can you look up a video of that there's
a link to it okay yeah right under an
undisclosed amount
i used to have sex with my body pillow
bro
as trailer moves today to augment all of
the pieces of this innovative web 3
platform
wait they're doing nfts now oh yeah yeah
yeah
how's they pivoted into the crypto space
in the last uh six months all right here
i'm just going to read kavanaugh's quote
combat sports like music have widely
diverse styles and audience
fight pfc
is indeed another wildly popular genre
no it's not you [ __ ] wild popular
duties
you know what's the most popular combat
sport
beating off
they should acquire olympic beating
true
and trailer is pumped to take it to the
next level globally
said ryan cavanaugh we admire the risk
takers and those that see around corners
to create and deliver entertainment and
action for everyone as trailer con
as chiller continues to invest
in the innovators and events that
redefine the shield so experiment in
diverse combat sports sector driller but
shut up ryan go ahead play them 700
views okay yeah yo this is wildly
popular wildly popular combat sport with
700 views
uh i'll leave it muted for the music
so why is this family friendly in boxing
isn't he's going to try to kill each
other
like they're swinging hard bro
sorry but no one wants
to watch this and he's like we need to
spend
70 million dollars acquiring these guys
i'm telling you right now pillow
fighting is the future bro welcome
ladies and gentlemen to thursday night
pillow fight from the del rio this is uh
listen now
not to denigrate you could play just
mute it not to denigrate the athletes
here but this is the dumbest thing i've
ever seen i mean it's it's goofy and
kind of fun i guess
yeah yeah yeah but like they're
presenting as if yeah they're gonna
change the game with this [ __ ]
wearing a shirt that says pain is
weakness leaving the body this is not a
guy that sees the
the humor the humor and what he's doing
all right guys let's see
you all ready for this this is actually
what a b has been uh training for
[ __ ] i wish
yeah this is this is sick dude oh a
little oh oh oh
yo
this is crazy ryan kavanagh scouting
talent in the audience
be epic if we saw him standing there
i can't believe this is real let me hear
the commentary all right
first and foremost we want to thank them
for their service i want to thank them
for participating in uh fight psc for
the fighting
championship uh this has been a more
cautious fight than what we've seen
uh with the two younger
uh the other fights
there's not a drop of humor in this i
believe or irony or self-awareness
what is he actually how does i'm
actually surprised how dry this is
it reminds me of that movie idiocracy
really the world has gone to [ __ ]
so if i've seen other sports that are
like goofy like this and what you're
right ethan like usually they're pretty
self-aware and kind of like they'll come
out in goofy outfits
i participated in a well not
participated but i i shot a trampoline
dodgeball tournament once
it's fun and it was very goofy and
self-aware and the commentators were
just like laughing the whole time but
this is like dead serious
no this is a combat sport
a family-friendly combat sport
i just love that ryan saw this and he
was like we we need this
we need this in our portfolio
i'm blown away by this man
all right thank you dan yeah he says
we've just acquired another wildly
popular genre
and we're pumped 700 views and we're
pumped to take it to the next level
globally
it's clear that trailer fight club is
the future of combat sports
as the fastest growing platform on its
accelerated path
chiller will soon overtake the ufc
mm-hmm
good luck with that
oh man what a [ __ ] loser
ryan cavanagh he's going to go bankroll
i'm telling you i'm not all the attorney
fees we're going to win from them i'm
never going to see a dollar they'll be
gone yeah i think
unfortunately right well and that i
there that was another article that
popped up about triller um that's in the
talk is that um
one of the main
jake paul lawsuits against one of the
the re-uploaders or whatever uh they
just dropped the case because they
weren't able to
find sufficient evidence essentially oh
well they couldn't probably find the
person to serve and they weren't able to
find that it's just a youtube account
yeah
but it said in the judge's dismissal
that they also admonished them because
the the evidence that they provided was
just like screenshots of
nothing like there was like they didn't
actually have any evidence that they
pirated the video essentially
and in that article they say that
of all the people that they've sued so
far they've only won one of the lawsuits
and they were default and they were
awarded or they wanted a hundred and
seventy thousand dollars and they were
awarded fifteen grand so they've
got 15 grand out of all of these
lawsuits so far i mean they've had to
have spent by the way really how it was
calculated they won that a default
judgment against someone who didn't
respond that's why they won right it
wasn't one on merit right i don't know
how the the
winnings were decided
every view
counted as 50 bucks right which is what
they were selling tickets for which
which is what we've been saying from the
beginning
that we'll just [ __ ] pay you 50
for every for the 30 views whatever it
was yeah call it a day
yeah that would have made a lot more
sense than dragging this out meanwhile
it was like ethan's going to jam a
[ __ ] idiot
uh in 2021 social media company triller
launched an aggressive hundred million
dollar legal campaign against entities
who streamed jake paul ben askram
it really hasn't gone to plan
in fact triller has now dismissed all of
its claims against its main target
and in other cases most of the banks
have turned into whimpers
film daily okay the big first people of
assault targeted many services
individuals prior to the fight
uh the first site film daily.com which
together with other defendants
found themselves on the end of a hundred
million dollar
lawsuit
i don't see you dismissed its own case
where's my dismissal you [ __ ] seriously
you dumb [ __ ]
somebody just sent a super chat for five
bucks said uh
the one of the pillow fighters is a
co-worker theirs
oh really yeah
well give your give my thanks to an
elite athlete marco do they are they
like really into it or are they
self-aware that is that it's goofy i'm
curious
these lawsuits are so dumb man i've
spent so much money on time on this [ __ ]
it's it's so [ __ ] up and stupid
um
yeah
of course of course trailer is going to
go bankrupt it's managed by ryan
kavanagh he's literally incompetent
in every fiber of his being is
incompetence he's not even bright
the only thing he's apparently good of
is convincing people
that he can make them money
i don't know how he got a single person
to invest in trailer after after the
utter failure of his last comment i'm
just shocked man
yeah chad has a good idea for a new
event for ryan a feather tickling
contest
and new combat sport yeah
he would see that and be like
let's drop 100 milli on this this is the
future
how much again 890 uh million uh lost in
uh 2021.
i think it was like 820 million 320
million last year
oops
that's that is insane numbers so how was
he get who's giving him that money
who
who the [ __ ] these investors are so dumb
like you think rich people like this is
proof that investors are [ __ ] dumb oh
yeah they're not even smart it's just
that just proves to how easy it is to
make money when you have a lot of money
and they just they just shotgun it and i
guess it's because it only takes one
you know facebook to become
a 100 billion dollar company to make it
worth their while but i mean it's it's
like uh the that movie just came out
about the theranos woman or whatever
yeah i mean she got
elizabeth holmes insane amounts of
investments and like the idea was
transparently [ __ ] dumb like just
unbelievably stupid and that story is
people
with so much money the thing is that
this is ryan kevin he already has a
massive l she was like unknown at least
she was yeah starting from also what
really confused me is because they lost
almost a billion dollars last year okay
yeah
how much money did theranos raise it was
like a billion dollars
so i don't understand why that's such a
big scandal and somehow ryan's raising
this much money well it took a long time
for that to uh yeah holmes raised 945
million yeah so she he ryan
is here
do you see what i'm saying like the
scale of the loss
the scale of the amount of money he's
getting it doesn't make any sense to me
because the the amount of losing he's
doing right now is is like only
rivaled by the hugest failures ever yeah
i i guess it's because at least at least
triller exists
you know what i mean
the theranose thing was just fraud top
to bottom like they they didn't have the
product that they claimed they did their
you know triller sucks but like you can
download the app so at least that i
guess
it's not outright fraud and now they're
going public can you imagine can you
[ __ ] imagine what does it see see
change or something let me look at their
stock
was there any other ryan cavanaugh stuff
that we skipped over
that we can get to now i mean there just
really hasn't
been many
updates i mean that was those two the
pillow fighting thing in and
this news about the
lawsuit was the only relatively recent
sea changes popping off guys
actually it's doing really well
it went from
a dollar to a dollar 40. well this was
when they made their announcement right
so it went up quite a bit for a minute
it's kind of leveled out but that's good
i think it's doing good
great investment
it's [ __ ] insane
i mean well when you pull out max i
guess
this is the lifetime of the stock it
doesn't look that good
yeah not as good
uh
i mean yeah it's just
any new brad the bull post or anything
not that actually it's ryan's cuckold
brad the ball
i thought we were gonna avoid oh we
weren't going to do that talking about
that
do your own reason not as an insult i
just think if he's into that it's fine
but if it is cuckold deserves
some love and
attention too
oh the og surf conspiracy
i'm down
look at this just to follow up on what
you were saying
there's a lot more than just these
people but these are people that have
invested in the elizabeth holmes thing
henry [ __ ] kissinger
jim mattis the former secretary of
defense under trump
george schultz
uh former secretary of state
the former ceo of wells fargo
another secretary of defense two
secretaries of defense of the united
states military no these weren't
investors they were on the board oh on
the boards even worse yeah
awesome someone said dude it doesn't
seem like you're starting a company it
seems like you're getting ready to
invade a country
right yeah
rupert murdoch you know owner of uh news
corp fox and all that
invested uh 5.8 million dollars in this
[ __ ] blood scanning scam
it's awesome
yeah but like you'd have to be
significantly dumber right now to put
money into trailer
i mean at this point yeah yeah well just
put it in a furnace i think that's why
they pivoted so hard to this
quote-unquote web 3 buzzword stuff in
the last couple months because that's
like
the latest
trend that's got suckers parting with
their money
all right so we're going to go into a
ryan kavanaugh og surfer conspiracy this
is really interesting i like to pee
really bad though we're at two hours
actually i'm gonna go pee and then we'll
do og surfer
okay
it's great and we're already on the
topic let's just do it you guys put work
into this right i mean this is a deep
rabbit hole yeah this was this was a few
months in the morning yeah yeah
a lot of help from the fupa troopers as
well on the subreddit
this is a huge collaboration now do you
guys have pictures of the og surfer
commenting on his uh instagram posts and
stuff if i'm not mistaken we have
everything okay good long section i'm
gonna go pee real fast i'll be right
back uh maybe you can set it up a little
bit
okay uh so
there is this account og surf which
seems like a very generic account
doesn't seem really real
and somehow it's engaging with ryan
and uh
it's just very fishy i don't want to
spoil the fun without ethan here
but there's definitely some fishy stuff
going on the guy has like eight
followers
but somehow ryan is always engaging with
him and vice versa
and uh
stay tuned it's gonna be it's gonna be a
juicy one dan what do you got
uh
i was just pulling up uh today's super
chats uh because i have not been paying
attention to it much today so let's
let's get let's get these super chatters
a little love why don't we
uh here i'm going back to the top of the
episode here
oh there's actually a lot today
holy [ __ ]
people people
here we go here's the beginning
uh
the show is a bright light in a dark
world wow
it's a little dramatic
but it's true it's true
f all the haters family family family
yes uh i'd like to propose to cam
i'm sorry this is all i could afford uh
cam
uh
cup of soup has a 10 dowry for you what
do you think you in
[Music]
camp some wait say that again somebody
wants to marry you uh they have ten
dollars for dowry what do you think uh
no thanks that's a pass
okay
sorry sorry
uh bunny ethan
you know like money ethan ah that's good
bunch of [ __ ] comedians samantha joe
uh what is more likely to be on time the
ace family's mortgage payment or h3 tv
yeah got em that's pretty good
uh message deleted
sick
shout that's also from cup of soup
that was actually a mistake i gotta
admit to a mistake there
he was
saying that the tick tocker that we've
been reacting to
that does the mouth stuff
his brother apparently passed away
unexpectingly
[Music]
a bunch of stuff i'm trying to give him
a sad one
see you in vegas
um i hope that's not
literal like you're going to be stalking
us
i mean we run into you that's that's
cool that's not a problem at all but um
it's a little ominous that message
they're gonna be in our walls
my grandpa's a stripper in vegas i can
set you guys up he's got some bitties
hell yeah
a a male
stripper
who has
titties and is a grandfather
okay
you check that out yeah
uh 20 dollars speaking of halal
a match with a guy on tinder's bio said
i heard you're looking for halal
boyfriend what does that mean help
not to be insensitive i'm just curious
as to what halal means um
jay i appreciate the twenty dollars you
can just you can just google stuff you
don't have to pay twenty dollars to make
a super chat you know what you can't
google to ask a question you can't
google this answer okay if it's in his
bio
that means he's gonna act hillel in
front of you and then behind your back
he's going to go drink and party and
he's full of [ __ ]
90 chance
there you go doesn't call it out worse
wow
all right so
um
did i hear something about a pro a male
prostitute with not a prostitute a
stripper
uh who is a grandfather to one of our
viewers and they said that he's got big
titties
nice so there's there was a lot going in
going on in that description there
uh lap dance maybe
for your birthday some bitties some old
bitties titties also just got a message
like what happened to dan's chair
same as always what what is that are you
saying the scorpion what do you
what happened to it damn what happened
to it what happened i'm in it i'm in the
cockpit i'm gonna be a different angle
okay let's let's it's a different angle
so maybe yeah maybe it's just i don't
know the chairs here all right so before
i get into the og surf conspiracy let me
just say this disclaimer it's just that
this is a conspiracy
based on observations and assumptions
we are very much
drawn uh coming to our own conclusion
here
are your own conclusions
yeah i mean we don't know
that og surfer
is ryan kavanagh
this is just a presentation of evidence
that we formulated
and uh it's just that it's just a
conspiracy that that we've we've made up
here
so with that being said
let's get into it so there's a website
or a user here
now was this account always private ab
um to my knowledge it was he follows me
or follows the pocket og surfer looks
like a 17 year old guy right i mean
that's a young man
santa monica
born and bred positive vibes only
let's all love and learn every day
family first
father dehaze and zella
and the shit's fake
but that's like a 17 year old that dude
doesn't have two kids does he
maybe it's an old photo oh my god
i just backtraced that photo oh we have
that we have that yeah that was already
yeah that's sorry
love still send that please because it
needs to be updated
well there you go
okay so
the reason that we this og surf account
came on our radar catch him hot
is first of all he started following
random fans on instagram
okay
and people were posting on the subway
like who is this
totally red dude oj surfer og surfer
started following you
followed by ryan cavanaugh
cav puppet requested to follow me what
should i do
now the also kavanaugh has a history of
running puppet accounts which was proven
in the wikipedia wars
right he was banned on wikipedia for
running multiple soccer puppets i
remember the exact number but i think it
was like eight
so this is a known um
strategy yeah known strategy of the cav
cav
um here's our first reddit post
of someone alleging
they have proof
that kavkav has a burner account and
talking
to himself about himself so let's take a
look at the original evidence here
so here is og surfer saying maybe and
he's tat once again tagging
we know his boomerass has done this
before he's trying to tag companies and
instagram
descriptions
to boycott me hbo max and at honey
condone death and our threats
that's what i've been getting from his
followers
right cav wait og surfer has been
getting that
og surfer yeah our fans have been
threatening the r word oh g surfer
why why would they do that to some
random account
okay so
um
i've been getting uh
i've been getting from his followers
since i posted support for you a few
weeks ago oh this was a comment under
one of couch's posts yeah probably just
being like doing great my children's my
children's lives were threatened
maybe they're trying to appeal to 13 to
18 year old future convict convict
demographic this is scary and the fact
that nobody's doing anything about it is
sad and unnerving ryan cavanaugh
responded to him
well if you look at these characters
it's pretty obvious and i mean the lack
of social
um
literacy is is
obvious between the two of them again
posting a youtube link
and an instagram comment which is not
hyperlinked
what does the link go to by the way do
you guys know yeah it's it's actually
the next link that doc he posted a link
twice by the way i think he thought if
he did it again it might work
but
it takes you to some weird
account on youtube that's all like
talking [ __ ] oh yeah i think he i think
ryan kavanagh
made a youtube channel
dedicated to trying to expose me
somebody did
but so the the link is really
interesting because if you go to the the
youtube channel which we will do next
it has as much views
actually less even views than trailer's
own youtube page
so nobody knows about this page that is
committed only to
exposing me and somehow ryan kavanaugh
is linking it
in his comments now here this is the
avatar for og surfer
obviously if you just type surfer male
brown hair it's the first image that
comes up i even just did it in real time
yeah i wasn't the first but i just hot
brown hair surfer is that what he really
typed something like that
he did man again i i cannot emphasize
he's so bad at this how bad he is at
tech and owns a tech company
allegedly
so let's go to the next one
okay
this accounts on private
oh is this i just looked at everything
okay
yeah
i saw everything
okay so this is when people first
noticed the og surfer cav cav connection
is that he was having an imaginary
conversation about how my fans were
doing all these horrible things
they count barely the account has a fake
avatar
okay
um
now it turns out og
surf claims to have known ryan kavanagh
forever
he po he said stepped up my game a bit
almost drowned but the rush was insane
real comment by the way
someone said how did such a small
account get a follow back from some
random ceo who kind of looks like harvey
weinstein
og surf said known ryan
since childhood
someone said fake account law hashtag
surf adrenaline bali
whatever that is i don't know
probably recommend it
so yeah why do they follow each other
right
this tiny account with like no followers
so they're best friend since childhood
ryan's response that he's posting to
again this is a 217 subscriber channel
that only ryan has ever linked to
called phone jacker
2.0
while they're still posting four hours
ago
the exclusively only post ether klein
hate videos
exclusively
they're using canva for their thumbnails
just as a side note they're using what
canva
oh
shout out to cambodia shout out to
sponsor we love canva yeah
hey considering uh ryan's technical
literacy that's pretty good that's a
great ad for canva anyone can do it
let's see frenemies 2 hypocrisy and
grift 32 minutes
wait hold on if deserve a voice
[Music]
usually there's no voice
being a taekwondo competitor in his day
ethan in her son's new political show
leftovers is probably not doing as well
as they expected what
we haven't even made absolutely
three months it's a big update yeah
never had a voice prior yeah but i mean
i always assumed he was paying someone
to do this anyway yeah
and therefore they've resorted to trying
to generate publicity through drama and
bait high-profile polarizing people to
come on their show it's clear to me that
ethan and hassan want to catch the giant
wave of culture wars between the left
and the right and
this is the new video just posted four
hours ago
it's 30 minutes long it's got a voice to
it
so pretty interesting yeah so that right
but this this was just posted four hours
before this magnus opus was posted
the videos are really weird like
n-word h3 it's just like bottom of the
barrel [ __ ] you know
um
if you look at the video it's titled uh
uh brigading the short
oh they have shorts too right yeah if
you just go to home it's on the home
page
yeah and it's like textbook
this one right here no to the right of
it this one yeah brigading let's see
it's like
sounds like
you know who spot on
talking about
the problem with social media
influencers but grading uh
is there not audio
so wait there's no audio
[ __ ] really thought this would
pop off on youtube
i like how the article says ratio
explains what we're showing me yeah yeah
this is called now this is the kind of
content that ryan thinks is going to pop
off on shorts
the man clearly understands his own
platform trailer
let's check a comment
what up
keep oh two seconds ago
keep up the great work
i thought i might have an interesting
lead there
so
somehow ryan kavanagh
is the only person in the world that's
ever linked
to this tiny channel dedicated only to
my controversies
right what are the chances
oh dan wait dan made it dan knows where
the bodies are buried and wants to get
paid oh [ __ ] this evil job on you dad
he's a greedy filthy rich he throws
around his money the title is dan is
quote joking
the strings behind the scenes and
youtube you know he tries to ruin his
enemies
but uh let me tell you that um i'll
spill the [ __ ] beans on all of it if
you don't pay me one million dollars
today okay
this isn't a [ __ ] joke yeah let's
talk about it after the show okay all
right and you know what else i can
depend on
is your head is so [ __ ] clean that
day bro
immaculate [ __ ]
to deliver that money in cash by
midnight tonight
or i'm ending your [ __ ] career all
right
and i'll take the money in our mark 20s
dude they got me so good
they actually think dan's in hell they
don't think that's a green screen i
think the fire is real behind him too
yup right
yo they're so they're their building
code is to such
the working conditions are so unsafe
their building's on fire exposed
i do appreciate that you paid up on that
though by the way
yeah of course i don't want that dirt
out there
best of the best ek
yeah this shit's crazy what the [ __ ]
yes so i mean
it's pretty obvious that uh
ryan kavanaugh is this evil genius
connected to this channel somehow
right i mean it's an assumption it's a
conclusion that i'm drawing i don't know
for sure
but
come on
oh and then why would here it says
hypocrisy self-reporting pirating a ppv
event nobody cares about this but ryan i
don't know why the ref called it i just
found that the obscene you know what i
wish i thought i felt that working long
for that it premiered you watched you
see that it wasn't possible oh you did
it as a live premiere
big premiere
yeah
i watched the whole i i bootlegged it i
pirated it
1.5 million people here they're talking
about you ian in the comments
i swear ian has been fed up for a long
time phone jacker said i agree
job security is what's holding him back
i'm sure also ethan was clever to hire
his girlfriend ethan always tries to
engineer loyalty
in thoughts
thoughts
you know that person was like really
deep into the
way
i didn't pay for that [ __ ]
[Music]
i almost did but ian came through with
the link
sorry
that's not what happened though i was i
was a lone gunman
i was a lone gunman oh and then they're
trying to expose ela for being in the
military army
uh which she's obligated to do as i said
she was all we're gonna do woke ela is
not gonna like this woman
i don't know this channel's wild bro
so there you go there's ryan's
he's working overtime you know
um
so as we know if you reserve res uh
reverse search the end the image i mean
we should make one with ryan cavanaugh's
head on it to add here
you know
now all of the og surfer images also
are from
a adobe stock image
oh from from his instagram page yeah it
used to be public
correct and every single post of him
surfing or whatever or from the beach
yeah we have an album of his actual
instagram before it's it you clearly
tell it's fake so here was his account
before it went private
now here's all of his posts
ripping shredding dude
[ __ ] shredding bro posts like this
that one's my favorite views
surf writer views for days pray for
waves
do we have in that album do we have
where that one came from because
that one has my favorite backstory oh
yeah um super [ __ ] low-res photos
well the low-res makes it look real but
it was from a uh a restaurant's uh
website um a restaurant
in malibu like it
you i was able to find that one by
literally just googling like malibu
beachside or whatever and it was like on
the second page of results and it was
from some restaurant or club or
something and it was like joffrey's or
something like that yeah so every single
post on og surfer
is you know a stock image
and then some of them are just super low
res like you know
which actually makes them look more real
oh there you go yeah i found it
immediately
let's see
this is from the uh there you go oh hell
yeah
[Laughter]
surf pray for waves my dude
i mean if ryan is running this or he's
paying someone to run this like the same
person running the website who knows
but um
all very interesting isn't it
i also think ryan is connected to i told
you all these phishing emails i'm
getting
oh really
i've been getting ever like for the
past month or two
when all this stuff started happening
with like the website and the wiki wars
and all this
i get like literally 20 emails a day
just trying to fish
[Music]
and i always report them as fishing or
spam and i think i'm totally [ __ ]
over whoever is paying to do that yeah
and so sometimes they they start to slow
down and sometimes they speed up still
get a bunch of them but he like here
here
hang on let me see if this is one
this one actually appears real
they slowed down a lot because i think
they realized that it wasn't happening
yeah somebody found that that website
that i just pulled up hasn't been
updated since 2006.
nice
nice fine
hey praying and waiting for the waves
there was another website we found which
is sort of like oh no way linkedin type
account and at the bottom of it of ryan
cavanaugh's profile says that he loves
surfing in malibu
coincidence
no no no no no pictures
that's harvey weinstein bro wait
what
oh you're right i wanted it with ryan
kavanaugh
i thought
well that's what it was a force of
nature
so the the account is fake
we can make that conclusion pretty
fairly he interacts
with and is followed by ryan cap now why
would ryan kavanagh follow
a fake account
that's commenting about how our fans are
harassing him why
why would he
it doesn't make any sense
does it
on this website it says ryan like man
ryan ain't surfing come on
it's at the very bottom under interest
tennis horseback riding
surfing in malibu cooking traveling
uh malicious
lawsuits
uh bankrupting businesses
yeah
harassing young does anyone have that
image of him in that weird white outfit
from the fight club
where he looked like he was in pajamas
or something
yeah
tell me that guy serves
i could find it
minnie donated 10 bucks and said one of
the weirdest things is ryan cavanaugh
really thinks it makes sense for some
washed up film producer to have young
beautiful dedicated fans cheering them
on in the instagram comments yeah i mean
it's just not
like a scenario that
makes sense at all
so when you look at the evidence
he's why is he following this account
ryan has a history of making
sock puppet accounts
it's it's hard to to
deny the
is compelling
to support that this man
is in fact
ryan kavanagh that is my theory
thank you og surfer ladies and gentlemen
oh we should let me check his wikipedia
article i haven't looked there in a
while
let me see how
there he is here's the
here's the real one yeah that looks
right
that's for sure
yeah he's an elite athlete he plays
tennis
horseback
and surfing
no dude be honest you sit in your room
all night
yeah look at this elite athlete
yeah this is the most [ __ ] up shirt
situation i've ever seen
what are you doing
oh this video was so funny too and he
was like he was trying to talk [ __ ] to
dana white or something and he was just
like stumbling over his words the whole
time too much wine sorry
oh my god
[Music]
you're such a loser bro
[Music]
and i really mean that
[Music]
because like i know you're rich and
success successful is debatable i mean
but like you really are a loser
and your wife is getting pounded by a
bull bro i mean like let's be real and
that's cool if you're into that
but if you're into cuck-holding i think
part of it is humiliation right so it's
not a stretch to say you're humiliated
by a bull brad the bull
i don't think it's a stretch to say that
come on now brad get up on in there now
don't make me hit the button
i was looking through an old dock trying
to find that outfit and i found the
headline it says
kev is being cut hundred percent proof
yeah i mean
definitely
ryan cuccano
who the [ __ ] wait the headline was that
you
stop
no comment
let's see
did we ever read
by the way did we ever read the whole
his whole wikipedia page
uh
his whole wikipedia i was cracking up
since
let me see let me see the look at that
march 13th roast he's still at it are
they always wondering if they're still
at it
march 21.
so this is a new person i haven't seen
that name throats is still crushing it
march 19. shout out throws
dude that's awesome bro bros is a
[ __ ] king and then popoki was the
other one yeah throats is real active
bro
thrust has it out he's he's
done a war harder than us well why
shouldn't he yeah he tried to he went he
threatened to sue him
he he was so uncalled for
what he did to these poor mods
who are working pro bono
but ever since he started a war man i
just this is like pure comedy reading
this not because it's fake or anything
but because it's so accurate now yeah
and you can just see that every
moment of his life is just oozing with
controversy like from the top down
ryan kavanaugh is an american film
financier he co-founded and served as
the ceo of relativity where he brokered
a deal between wall street investors and
major film studios he credited his risk
assessment algorithm with relativity's
initial success
after relativity filed for bankruptcy he
stepped down a ceo and faced several
lawsuits regarding his management
he later founded proximity media which
required a controlling stake of trailer
like that's accurate before it was like
ryan cavanaugh is the best
coolest [ __ ] in the world right
early life
i think we read this one but i'm gonna
read it again so good reincar was born a
jewish family he was raised in brentwood
attended brentwood his mother was in
real estate his dad was a dentist
yada yada
rank haven't attended uc santa barbara
and ucla but dropped out in 1996. in
2012 kavanaugh threatened the new york
the new yorker with legal action for its
reporting on him including its report
that he dropped out of university
kavanaugh claimed to have officially
graduated from ucla and be enrolled in
the phd program at usc the new yorker
stood by its reporting
while subsequent sources reported
kavanaugh finished a degree in 2012 the
wall street journal reported that there
was no record of him taking any classes
at usc so that's his early life
basically lying about his education and
then suing people
for calling him out on it
yeah there you go that's his early life
that's that's what he accomplished
you know
let's see early career
after using leaving ucla kavanaugh
started a short-lived venture capital
firm
kavanaugh's uncle connected the family
with john peters and kevin and his
father leveraged the producers hollywood
connections to raise 175 million
there you go there's your answer dan
you're like how the [ __ ] this guy make a
like venture capital firm
straight up
yeah straight out of college
yeah he really worked his way up
climbed that ladder
an investment fund for the younger
kavanaugh's company several investors
sued kavanaugh alleging fraud you don't
say
and suits were settled out of court
including a potential 5 million lawsuit
from john peters the guy who uh
his uncle leveraged i don't know who
john peters is but
hey what do you think another guy
[ __ ] hates his guts
michael srilik a los angeles executive
who invested six million dollars in
kavanaugh's company on the express
condition the funds only be invested in
publicly traded companies sued him for
negligence
after learning the funds were invested
in private companies instead
an arbitrator found that kavanaugh was
clearly negligent
and steric won 7.7 million dollars in a
judgment against kavanaugh
of course he never received payment
because kavanaugh successfully argued
that he has he was virtually penniless
and his business was on the verge of
bankruptcy at the time of judgment and
that's his early career
is that good or what
so see early life lying about his
education and suing publications for
exposing him early career
uh
somehow got 175 million dollars and
[ __ ] lost it all he said he was
penniless
imagine losing 175 million dollars how's
that possible you put that in the s p
500 you'd be a billionaire by now
incredible
force of nature
you guys want to hear about relativity
media
uh
you're gonna read that whole section
dude it's so good you gotta give your
throat a break we're going two and a
half hours you told me to cut you off 30
minutes ago do a pull do people want
this or they want me to take a break
i i find it so good
i've been re i've been meaning to read
uh read this to you guys
cock-a-doodle-doo thank you
here's
cock-a-doodle-doo
[Music]
i love that shirt man
[Music]
you kind of gave him a chad jaw though
cam
look at that chad jawline
[Music]
so i don't have the stream open what's
the vote here uh keep going has it
70 percent
oh
[Music]
okay listen it's been a while the people
want to know
there's an update
bro
oh it's ch look at that chatting
[Music]
and some cav worth squidward
or
good word
all right so basically he's had a great
early life no controversy in his early
life or career early career
now let's get to relativity media
kavanaugh co-founded relativity media by
the way let's just set the stage here he
just lost 175 million was sued by a ton
of investors i couldn't pay them back
because he says he was virtually
penniless okay splash cut relativity
media
co-founded it in 2003 and 2004
with entertainment executive lynnwood
springs
with a relationship with warner bros
that opened up a cavanaugh to broker a
deal between the film studio and a hedge
fund that would finance films
uh in early 2000s wall street investors
who were described as a wash in cash
we're looking for investments
opportunities outside the stock market
yo what do you mean a wash with cash
give me some money
i'll do something with it
is it that easy to get money from rich
people
i don't
yo bro i've got a crazy idea yo
just give me the money bro sick
relative media took advantage of the
ready investment funds to broker deals
that channeled wall street
blah blah blah
blah he is using investment money to
finance films
and then he came up with this really
dumb idea
that he could predict the odds of a film
being a commercial success
kevin i held albert einstein as his hero
man shut the [ __ ] up you're og surfer
and he would write long equations on
white boards at investor meetings bro
god so bad
although kavanaugh frequently cited the
model's accuracy up to 85 percent a
source close to elliott management one
of the company's principal and earliest
lenders estimated it to be much lower no
[ __ ] you guys went bankrupt
some investment banks and industry
executives had also cast doubt on the
model's efficiency
by the early 2010s the model ultimately
proved unprofitable with box office
bombs overwhelming
only
it produced box office bombs
overwhelmingly
over
only a few commercial successes
[ __ ]
not good
i'm trying to skip all this [ __ ] um
let's see
cut to the chase here
here in november 2011 relativity media
was desperately short on funds investor
ron berkel arranged a series of loans to
kavanaugh's company exchange for
interest
industry speculation service that burke
would oust kavanaugh from relativity
media in favor of his friend ryan
kavanagh
you guys hear that
austin who
anyway relativity media filed for
bankruptcy
blah blah blah
shortly after the bankruptcy rka films
one of its lenders sued them
for miss spending its marketing funds
and called kavanaugh a quote con man
and alleged he was operating a scheme to
defraud investors quote
they also allege kavanaugh used their
invested funds for personal expenses
relativity media denied the money was
diverted saying rka film finances
understood the money would go into a
general corporate account
relativity media of course countersued
for 200 million dollars
relativity media's operations and
recognition
remained under the supervision of a
bankruptcy court
cavanaugh eventually stepped down
leading to his resignation kavanaugh had
been absent from the company's office
for weeks
in 2018 relativity media file for
bankruptcy again
and arranged to sell its assets the
united states trustee's office argued
the bankruptcies seemed to benefit
kavanaugh
and the new buyer ultra v holdings at
the expense
of relativity's
creditors their
filing uncovered that relativity media
may have paid kavanaugh
2.6 million between april
and november
while the company remained delinquent
on payments of from the first uh
bankruptcy case man this guy ryan
cavanaugh seems
shady
doesn't he
like the definition of the word
right
yeah
um in 2008 hedge fund investor kerry
metz filed a lawsuit stating kavanaugh
defrauded him by conning him into making
an initial 10 million investment into
relativity
matt's suit was amended
to
amend a complaint from his initial suit
alleged kavanaugh duped him into making
an additional 2.5 million investment
as relativity was on the verge of
bankruptcy
the first suit had been dismissed by a
new york judge who determined to release
in the bankruptcy organization plan
barred uh mets cause of actions
it's just a who's who of who's [ __ ] of
who of people he's [ __ ] over
and this is uh one of our favorites in
june 2018
an arbitration case found that
relativity media executive have
fabricated a memo
accusing relativity media former
co-president adam field of sexual
harassment a forensic audit of
relativity media found the memo had been
generated by a user named kavkav
relativity media submitted the falsified
memo to court two weeks before fields
dude this i love bro this is just
i'm just reading a wikipedia page you
guys sure are
yeah relativity media submitted the
falsified memo to court two weeks before
it feels wrongful termination
yeah he won 8.4 million dollars from
kavanaugh how's the guy have any money
left
and you know as soon as i sense boredom
i'm just gonna read this part under
philanthropy which is my favorite
the chat is keeping me entertained
okay good yeah that's good
yeah
this guy this one you guys are gonna
want to listen to okay
he's a great
philanthropist according to former
relativity media executive kavanagh
often
pledged large charitable gifts and then
billed them to the company
in 2007 kavanaugh presented habitat for
humanity for an oversized check pledging
one million dollars
and announced he would become a
fund-raising
chair for the charity however as of 2015
kavanaugh has not yet donated the
promised funds
the man came out with a giant check for
a million bucks and never gave him the
[ __ ] money
isn't that great
i think there's a video of it can you
try to find it of him bringing the
oversized check
oh my throat is killing me it wasn't
worth it huh guys
you guys wanted to
start to do this thing they always say
dabs for dan
and then they went around with every
person in the office like opiates for
olivia damn that's dark
opiates for olivia
um let's see
you'll find that habitat for humanity
you should i will end on that okay my
throat is literally
eviscerated think of
a worse thing to do in the last half
hour of the show when you're trying to
save your throat then just sit here and
read a wikipedia page from top to bottom
there you go
there's a video though i've seen okay
so he he gets the accolades he gets
everyone loving on him but he never gave
the [ __ ] money
it's a pretty common move with these big
showy uh
charity donations let's not talk about
making money
anyway
[Laughter]
did i just realize how much tai lopez is
just a dollar store garyvee and now
oh i think i found it yes i knew it was
out there i found it right after you
uh
hey i don't see him handing the giant
[ __ ] oh here it is here it is yes i knew
it this is him
look at this [ __ ] guy bro on friday
friday
look how happy everyone is
wow
they even made him this plaque
so when i was a teenager about uh 10
centuries ago
uh my mom brought me along to my habits
at work
i just bear in mind as all this is
happening is that he never gave them a
cent
go ahead as he gets given me a hammer
and a hard hat and said time to get to
work right which as at the time i didn't
even know how to clean my room let alone
build a wall it was a big shock god he's
so curious
this is what blows me away my mother how
did this guy
yeah it's just like
how [ __ ] stupid are these people to
fall for this this guy
sucks on how to use one
it was that moment to put habitat for
humanity in my memory banks is something
that would be an important part of my
future you didn't donate to that
explained at the time that there were
those who wrote a speech she came out he
accepted their award
didn't give him we were there to help
those people be safe and have a home is
that awesome what was most memorable to
me however was that my mom who's a
hard-working mom worked on numerous
other charities was raising two kids and
one of the busiest people that i'd ever
met
actually took the time to go build just
like all of you
you are the true heroes and the ones who
deserve the thank you
money comes and i don't deserve the
thank you you're the true hero
something that we never get back and
something that all of you have given
you've given the gift of your time to
help make sure that others can cherish
their time you know it as well is it in
a safe and secure environment is there
no is there the giant show is in roslyn
carr uh it doesn't appear to be in this
clip
unfortunately oh
we had the picture yeah we had the
picture but they even made us as an
award they literally lost money doing
this for him
didn't even leave this guy and he's
suing me he's spending hundreds if not
millions of dollars suing me and he owes
them a million bucks a charity i'm
seeing in a variety article that after
some discussion an agreement was reached
habitat received a payment from
relativity for twenty five thousand just
before
a year later
look at they threw you like a festival
bro
oh that is [ __ ] incredible
[Laughter]
and they later
see in the same source
said uh relativity delivered another ten
thousand dollar check
in a holiday card
so that's nice 35 000 35 what is that of
a million 3.5
yes
plus the 2.5 percent so a total of no i
already added that oh you already added
that
okay yeah that's great
i said what the [ __ ] you such a scum bro
oh my god
yeah life isn't fair if you're wondering
if you're broke and wondering why
this guy is successful and rich well
i mean yeah
he's rich i think he has like a
beautiful house in malibu oh i'm sure
yeah he's he's put money away oh yeah
right on uh cuckold beach
great beach with brad yeah
brad when are you coming my wife needs
to get [ __ ]
brad get over here
my wife's waiting on you guys got my
finger on the button
he's into it i'm not king shanging him
that's the king you can't tame the bull
dan but that's the key but how what am i
doing wrong that's the kink he likes to
be
humiliated
yeah that's true hey brad
come on over here and [ __ ] my wife
my penis is so small
and yours
is so big
brian is so successful in selling real
estate
me
i've lost everything
you've got a big [ __ ] and you're
successful [ __ ] my wife please
[Music]
i'm gonna type messages about ethan
klein from ogs og surfer as brad [ __ ]
my wife
now it's nice to talk about ryan again
it's been too long yeah it's been too
long
uh brad's always closing yeah
no i've been i've looked at it i don't
know
just the name of it always closing the
deal on your wives everywhere
he looks he looks like a handsome
version of moses it's super weird
um
don't don't involve this guy are you
kidding me like i gotta cut this off
this is this is not good you're about to
get this guy [ __ ] harassed wait we
have already shown he has pictures with
bryce hall and [ __ ]
he dude okay wait before i show it let's
just talk about it let's not show it
because i then i'm gonna get [ __ ] for it
wait before we show it this guy doesn't
have anything to do with our beef with
ryan it's not it's not really we should
not be directing our audience he is he
is a public figure
i'll tell you how
they have a very public media company
that they're posting with tick tock
stars here's a picture of him with bryce
hall
from february 16.
but you're right we don't need to show
them why did you bring it up why
i know why
you why the [ __ ] did you message me from
when we previously talked why did you
message me that and then be like erase
me from this conversation i like to get
dan a little heated before we leave so
what the [ __ ] you get me in trouble then
bounce
here's a picture but you're right we
don't need to show it
we don't need to bother them
he's a bull though
ryan's enough of a [ __ ] up in his
professional life we don't we don't need
to can i just show you what i i'm sorry
i just want to show you what's [ __ ]
his wife
oh my god
that's brad the ball
like don't don't go to this page you
don't
this is this is over the line no it's
not
stop
how is it over the line
because you're you don't have
because this guy doesn't have anything
to do he's not suing you right i got
caught up in the meme
it was just funny
it's funny it's funny but i agree with
maybe
davey's the one that sent it to me i
want to instigate it all baby's the one
that sent this
i agree
i'll do it for you guys should i go
through for you guys
anyway yeah but like this picture is
awesome
but can i just download it and then show
the photo
he's handsome that's all i'm saying
he's very handsome he's jacked as [ __ ]
he's like zero percent body fat that's
great that sounds like a fair middle
ground
what
just showing a picture of him yeah i'm
just saying like look what's [ __ ] his
wife that's fair
do we all agree
i mean it's all too late anyways you
already said the name of the account
i sent a picture he did it
we've shown the account before we've
looked at it before all right just show
the picture it's not like an insult
i sent uh just the picture yeah okay
like guys do not do nothing i
do not harass anyone we're talking about
do not go do not talk about it do not
bother them that includes ryan but i'm
just saying this is the guy [ __ ] his
wife
can you show up
please it's just we downloaded the image
that's brad the bull
yeah dude
who wouldn't want to take a ride with
brad the ball
my god
just saying
you're just saying just saying all right
that's it
i mean what an upgrade
me and start the music
cut them off start the music
yeah
from this
dan do you have a sensor button now
i was threatening to use it
but
it doesn't censor the uh
the screen unfortunately all right
anyway it's fine it's all good
so we will be back on wednesday
guys do not i'm not reading the chat i
don't know what people are saying but
obviously
i think it's funny to show how handsome
and jack this dude is
who is a public figure that ryan links
to them all the time he's posing with
tick-tockers but he has nothing to do
with this absolutely right
so besides that don't even bother anyone
involved in this don't do it don't do it
excluding ryan cavanaugh
or og surfer yeah
give more uh
ammo to ryan to make
youtube videos on his secret account
i don't think i said anything wrong i
just i don't want anyone to bother brad
the ball yeah exactly yeah it's just
that it's not
no i agree don't bother brad i've got
nothing to do with any of this
it's not his fault he's so buff and good
looking it is his fault he put a lot of
work into that
it's all his fault
i mean people say we know ethan dot and
it's not duh because every time
this happens
not all of you obviously but a handful
of you
go and start
leaving mean comments on people's
accounts they don't know that they could
be ryan cavanaugh sock puppets
trying to frame them that's true it
could be that it could be that we don't
know
but i just i'm saying it for the record
you know for for prosperity for prostate
that do not bother especially leave brad
the bull out of it
and brian cavanaugh and og surfer
and every eight stock puppet account on
wikipedia of ryan's
he's jack though man look at that
she probably gets real
all night dude he probably has crazy
stamina
[Music]
you